The Joe Rogan experience
day,
Joe Rogan podcast by night.
Rhonda,
I presume.
Good to see you again.
Good to see you too.
Last time I saw you,
I introduced you to the wonderful world
of head trauma.
Indeed,
Dr Rhonda got her first experience of a
live UFC event and just to preface it,
you really didn't know much about the
UFC at all before you went to this thing
with your husband and it was.
Well,
I'll put you.
You were pretty shocked.
Yes.
I mean to be honest,
I had no clue until the morning of or
the day before and that was like the
morning of the day before it's blank
that I looked it up and it was like I
saw people were like in a cage fighting
and I was like,
holy crap.
I thought it was,
you know,
totally.
I don't know even know what I was
expecting.
It was just some kind of wrestling thing
or something,
you know?
I think I was confusing it with the w.
w e e is that what?
Wrestling the ww something wrestling.
So Ufc,
I mean just these little three letter
acronyms,
acronyms.
So you had really never been exposed to
any sort of mixed martial arts.
That's so funny.
Not Mixed martial arts.
I mean I was,
you know,
aware of things like taekwondo and all
that,
but I just know that they exist and that
they're kind of cool.
And that's,
that's about it.
Had you ever been to a boxing match
before?
No,
I had never been to a boxing match and
I've really never really watched when
I've seen probably clips or pieces of
it,
like throughout my life at some point,
but I'm just no exposure in general.
I don't have a sports gene in my body
while I love to like work out and
exercise and you know,
I'm very addicted to the brain benefits
and other benefits I have never really
like watched sports or been interested
in it like in general.
And I try really hard because my dad is
a huge sports fan.
Oh love.
He plays baseball.
I mean he's 65 and he still plays
baseball on like a men's league.
So anyone watches football,
basketball,
any sport,
any like manly sport,
you know,
he,
he watches,
he knows everything about.
And he's not a big science guy,
so I try really hard to bond with him
when I'm with him.
I'm like trying really hard to be
interested or like he'll take me to a
padres game,
you know,
in San Diego and I'm like,
I try to like understand,
you know,
the,
like what's happening.
But it takes a little work for me.
Um,
with that said,
that whole,
that mma experience was very unique
because I've been to a baseball game.
I've been to a football game,
basketball game.
So those are the sports that I've
actually spectated live at some point in
my life.
But the MMA was a very different
experience.
Um,
I've,
it felt very like there was kind of a
tribal component to it where you've got
people cheering when the fighters are
coming down the aisle and I don't know
the way the music,
like drums and stuff,
we're going,
I something beating and then this,
the whole people fighting in a cage made
me feel like this,
you know,
times back in the Roman colosseum where
they'd go and watch people fight.
And there's a lot of that in it.
You know,
there's definitely a lot of tribal,
the tribal element of the music.
Yes.
Different people from different cultures
have different music,
like a lot of the country music guys or
country guys will come out to like
country songs and guys who were like a
more urban will come out to the rap
songs.
A lot of white guys come up with a rap
songs too,
but,
you know,
some guys would come out to like classic
rock and everyone's like,
Yay,
I love that song.
I'm going to root for this dude.
You know,
but it's uh,
there's definitely an element of that in
it.
The music was cool and that,
that I think that also gave that tribal
feeling,
but then the cheering and how people
were like,
I had it just,
there is something moving inside of me
that I was not expecting.
And then so it was cool.
And in that regard where it was like,
oh,
this feels like some unique experience
that I wouldn't get at.
You know,
they haven't ever experienced any sort
of other sport event that I've attended.
So when you said something was moving
inside of you,
you mean like you were emotionally
moved,
like you got excited,
your heart raced.
It was part of the community that you
know,
was like,
wow,
this is some kind of community that I
get to experience for a day.
Yeah,
it was,
it was some sort of unique event where I
felt like I was just,
you know,
connecting with these people that are
around me.
It's a very addictive community too.
I can imagine.
It was a lot of fun.
You know,
it was a lot of fun.
Aside from the me,
you know,
looking at the effects on the brain and
stuff a lot of these fighters are
experiencing.
Aside from that,
it was,
it was a lot of fun.
I really,
really liked it.
That was the thing.
We all went out afterwards.
A giant group of US afterwards went out
to eat and you just were wide eyed.
You had like,
like saucer eyes and you were like the
amount of damage that you just couldn't.
I couldn't stop calculating the amount
of damage that was going on to these
people's brains.
Irreversible damage.
Like yes,
well that and coupled with our
conversation the night before where,
you know,
denny was talking about friends that
were fighters that,
you know,
having memory problems and immediately
when he started describing some of those
characteristics,
I was like,
that sounds just like an Alzheimer's
patient and just because I wasn't really
aware of any of the MMA,
you know,
community,
what it involves,
what sort of,
you know,
it seems like there's a lot of,
there's not a lot of rules.
Like you know,
you can,
you can punch someone in the head and
you can kick,
you can choke,
you can,
you know,
boxing,
I don't think they can kick.
And so it seems like there was a lot of
other stuff going on that was very
traumatic.
It's so funny.
Listen to you describe it because
you're,
you're so educated in science and the
human body and the effects of vitamins
and various nutrients in the human body.
So to see you get your first exposure to
what's like a normal part of my life.
It's like a daily part of my life
essentially is being exposed to this
stuff.
So it's,
it's fascinating to watch you,
like,
I don't think they can kick in boxing.
You're so removed now.
It's like you're an alien from another
planet and landed in the world of MMA
for a day.
Yes.
That,
that,
that is kind of how I felt.
Wow.
But I'm right.
Right.
You're right,
you're right.
You're right.
Well,
there is a thing called kickboxing A.
There's a company called glory and they
hold these events on Spike TV,
which is a American cable channel and
they're allowed to kick that kick and
they can need,
they can't elbow though.
Um,
it's like a modified version of what's
called [inaudible] Thai and Moitai is
Thai boxing and in Thailand,
um,
they are the experts in this very
particular type of kickboxing where they
do a lot of clenching.
They grab a hold of each other and need
each other in the body and the head and
the elbow from the clench and they,
they throw a lot of leg kicks.
They're known for their,
they're kicking ability.
I've seen Muy Thai,
like on twitter and like,
you know,
tweeting at me and stuff.
But I really didn't know exactly what it
was and monetize pretty wild.
Actually.
I didn't even realize people used
kickbox.
I thought kickboxing was like a way to
work out.
Like I didn't realize there was actually
people fighting seriously.
Like I really,
really thought that it was just a way to
work out until just now,
wow,
that's so crazy.
I'm in another world.
I do a lot of.
I was telling my husband the other day,
like,
you know,
people on weekends,
they go out and they think they go
camping and they hike and they go and
they go to the woods and a fight,
you know,
see all these new things in the forest,
which I love to do by the way.
But every day what I did was I'm like
hiking and foraging through the human
body.
And it's like everyday I'm doing this
constantly and I do get a little,
um,
you know,
I'm,
I'm sort of sheltered from a lot of
other things because I'm just like,
oh,
he's reading about science and health
and mechanisms.
And so at times I am with other things
that are so common knowledge to people.
I'll kind of like blow people's minds
around like no,
I didn't know.
Like what other things are you
completely cultural norms that you're
completely unaware of?
Well,
a lot of sports things,
definitely at television stuff.
Um,
you know,
just any of that television world
and people always relate to commercials
and like I nothing,
it's like yours without a TV's
CV and I still don't relate to.
Someone just explained to me that the
show bones on Fox has been on for like
six years or something like that was on
the other day in a hospital waiting
room.
I was watching it and I was like,
what this show is,
how long it's been on and like spend on
forever.
I was like,
what?
Come on,
like there's so many shows.
I have no idea what they are.
I'll pass by US weekly.
And with someone on the cover,
you know,
she's leaving him.
She started like,
who the fuck is she?
Who's he?
Who apparently they're huge celebrities.
I have no idea who they are.
Yeah,
that's,
that's.
So I'm,
I'm in that sort of a mindset mindset,
so,
um,
but you know,
back to the,
to the UFC event,
um,
yes.
So the watching the event was really
exciting,
but I'm starting to look at,
you know,
these blows that people were taken to
their head and the choking,
there seems to be a lot of choking going
on and you know,
some of those sort of.
I was just from what little I knew at
the time it was already like,
wow,
this seems like,
you know,
some stuff's going down.
Basically smoking
though is not as dangerous as the,
the,
the issue with choking is annie
grappling.
You're gonna develop microtrauma,
you're gonna have disc issues.
As you get older you're going to have
the just a lot,
a lot going on with the spine,
you know,
and so there's some trauma,
but for the most part the choking is not
too dangerous.
There's one repeated issue that's been
happening a lot lately.
Never happened in the UFC,
but it's been happening in smaller
organizations and it's a very particular
move where someone will go for a take
down,
which is to the guy there standing up.
You try to take the guy down and then
the person who they're trying to take
down gets the guy in what's called a
guillotine choke and a good team choke
is your head is trapped under the armpit
and you have your forum or anything neck
and you're pulling up on the neck and
then the person who's caught in the good
team tries to take the person down by
like picking them up and trying to throw
them and they land on the guys head and
that people are becoming paralyzed from
it.
It's happened several times.
It's happened in training a couple of
times and tapping a couple times in
fights,
but it's enough of an issue where it's
starting to scare the shit out of me.
You know that guys who get caught and
good teams try to slam their way out of
it.
They try to pick a guy up and slammed
their way out of it instead of trying to
be technical and grab a hold of the hand
and try to work your way out of it.
It's just [inaudible] that choke is so
sudden when you get caught in it,
it's such a nasty joke that the,
the,
there's like one or two seconds where
you had with a guy who's really good,
where you have to breathe,
where you know,
otherwise you're,
you're,
you're pretty much going to go
unconscious.
So that's one thing I was wondering with
the choking specifically was,
you know,
because choking,
you can to some degree cause some
hypoxia in the brain so you know,
you're not causing ischemic damage,
which is like no oxygen getting into the
brain,
but you may have reduced oxygen in the
body compensates for that.
They know the body will because it
senses that less oxygen is getting the
brain.
It increases blood flow as a
compensation.
But if that can't,
if it can't compensate what happens,
you know,
you'll start to,
um,
eventually like your motor control will
get affected.
And I was wondering if they use that as
a technique like because then that the,
because they're choking their opponent,
now their opponents,
motor control gets effected.
No goals,
just put the guy of sleep,
which is even worse because that's the
next step,
which then you become the top.
Yeah.
So,
and there is that,
that hypoxic damage,
you know,
there is damage occurring,
what kind of damage has occurred and
when the going gets choked out,
completely asleep,
completely asleep.
So you're talking about,
you know,
not enough oxygen getting the brain for
just a couple of seconds,
a few seconds.
I'm one of the thing that can happen is
that you can have a lactate buildup.
So,
um,
the,
so your brain,
so you have a neurons and you have
supporting cells in your brain called
astrocytes and glial cells.
But astrocytes are a specific type of.
Glial cells are really important.
They do a lot of things for the brain
and they make up like 50 percent of the
human brain volume.
They actually,
um,
they use glucose and they use glucose in
a way where they don't need their
mitochondria.
So they use glucose through something
called glycolysis and the byproduct is
they make lactate.
And the reason they do this is because
the lactate then goes into the neuron
and it goes right into the Mitochondria
and is used to produce energy,
but that isn't needs to be coupled to
oxygen.
So lactate is,
um,
a really great source of energy for
neurons because it's,
it's not for the Neuron to convert
glucose into Piru,
um,
which then gets used as energy costs
energy,
but for lactate to get converted into
Piru Bait to then be used as energy,
it's thermodynamic dynamically favorable
because it doesn't cost any energy to do
that.
So,
um,
but this requires oxygen.
This is this oxidative phosphorylation
mechanism that I've talked about before.
Um,
but when you don't have oxygen there,
then the lactate can't be used by the
neurons.
And uh,
so lactate will then build up and can,
cause,
you know,
it can cause cell death when you have
too much lactic acidosis building up in
their brain.
Now that I don't,
you know,
with the amount of choking,
I don't think that's much of an issue
because this is more for like a real,
like real trauma,
like intense trauma,
more like a head trauma blow to the head
or um,
you know,
even like the rapid acceleration and
deceleration that occurs like car
accidents mostly.
Yeah.
I don't think that,
you know,
the blows to the head,
people's heads are moving,
but it's not as,
it's not like a car hitting you where
it's like really,
really rapid acceleration deceleration.
That's a real problem.
Um,
so I think,
you know,
once I started to dive into this,
I start to read about traumatic brain
injury.
Um,
and specifically I became interested in
that,
in it because of the Alzheimer's
connection and was like,
Whoa,
wait a minute.
Why are these young people coming down
with symptoms of Alzheimer's?
Like in like early,
early age like that,
there's,
there's some,
some connection between the way the
normal brain ages and something that's
happening with traumatic brain injury.
So I became really interested in,
started reading about it,
you know,
since I went to that a UFC event and I'm
really a fascinating,
you know,
I've been reading a lot about it and you
know,
these,
these fighters,
fighters,
nfl players,
you know,
people,
boxer boxing,
anyone that's taking blows to the head,
you know,
whatever sport,
that that's some,
you know,
in some regard,
I think even rugby,
things like that.
Um,
you know,
these,
these people have a uh,
increased incident of Alzheimer's in
some cases just,
you know,
two to three fold increased case if
Alzheimer's.
Um,
and,
and it's an earlier onset,
you know,
and it's very like indistinguishable,
indistinguishable in terms of like some
of the pathology that occurs in their
brain compared to like someone who's,
you know,
75,
80,
85 years old and getting Alzheimer's.
So,
um,
I started reading about this like,
what's going on?
Um,
and what happens is like even just a
single blow to the head,
um,
can cause,
you know,
it can increase the risk for Alzheimer's
and when you're having multiple
repetitive injuries that's,
you know,
increases the risk even more.
Um,
and so initially like there's a lot of
changes that happened,
but when you have a blow to the head,
you know,
you've got the acute damage that
happens.
So,
you know,
um,
tissue damage you can get,
like diffuse axonal injury,
things like that.
And that's from like a real trauma to
the head.
But you know,
even just like re mild repetitive trauma
is what happens is you get tissue damage
and you release a lot of reactive oxygen
species,
which I've talked about before which are
released every,
every day.
We're releasing that in our brains and
our other cells through just normal
metabolism.
Um,
it's kind of like a byproduct of normal
metabolism.
So people that are not getting brain
injury,
it's happening in a little bit each day.
But with a brain injury,
when you're,
when you're getting a blow to the head,
it induces a massive,
massive amount of release of it and it
starts to damage the manichees.
So which,
which,
uh,
form of protective membrane,
the brain and those cells start to die.
A reactive oxygen species as a
protective mechanism.
It causes cells to die.
And the reason it does,
I've talked about reactive oxygen
species before in the context of cancer.
When you get a little bit of reactive
oxygen species such as like normal
metabolism you can do,
you can cause damage to DNA.
And when you damage the DNA,
you can either repair that damage.
If you don't,
you can get a mutation eventually that
builds up and leads to cancer.
But if you have a huge burst of it,
like in the case where you're getting an
injury,
then you're talking about a protective
mechanism that kicks in,
which is like,
okay,
I need to kill the cell and the
reasoning to kill cells because I don't
want to get all that damage that's going
to cause me cancer.
So it's.
So it's a protective mechanism.
So it's killing cells to protect itself.
Yes,
that's,
that's the,
uh,
biological mechanism as to why this huge
burst of reactive oxygen species does
kill cells.
It's a,
you know,
it's a conserved and evolutionary
conserved mechanism and it really is
important,
like if you're,
if you stand,
that's why part of the,
you know,
underlying mechanism for radiation in
terms of like treating cancer radiation
is,
you know,
you're,
you're causing double stranded breaks in
DNA.
It's just like you're,
you know,
you're,
you're damaging the DNA and it's a huge
amount of damage.
So it causes cells to die.
Um,
so this is happening in the brain and
it's really not a good thing because in
the sense for this,
you know,
on the acute injury,
you've got these energy cells that start
to die and then astrocytes,
which like,
you know,
they are part of them like help form
some of the blood brain barrier.
They start to die and when those
astrocytes start dying,
that form the blood brain barrier,
what happens is the blood brain barrier
gets leaky.
And now you have things like,
um,
you know,
potassium chloride,
sodium leaking into the brain and
causing astrocytes to swell,
causing water to flow in and you get,
you know,
a Dema and the brain,
like I looked at this guy mark comic,
I think if you could go and you can see
like a picture of his swollen Dema like
head and it's just like unbelievable.
So that's part of the,
the cause of this edema.
So you've now what happens is that
reactive oxygen species,
those dead cells,
the blood brain barrier gets compromised
immediately when that happens,
these immune system and the brain gets
activated.
So you have another part of glial cells
called Microglia,
which are like the immune cells in the
brain.
They get activated when the blood brain
barrier gets damaged and they migrate up
and they're trying to plug up the hole.
So they're like,
oh my God,
you know,
the blood brain barrier has been
compromised.
So they might get up and start trying to
plug up the hole.
The problem is now you've activated,
activated this whole immune response
where it starts to.
Cause.
Yeah,
look at that.
I mean,
that's just so awful when you see a lump
like that fight should be stopped
immediately.
Yeah.
I would say was,
did he keep fighting after that fall,
another round and one won the final
round with a,
with a big injury like that.
That's just unbelievable honestly.
Um,
so in your opinion as a medical
professional,
when you see that kind of swelling,
um,
this is,
this is not a guy who should be hitting
the head again.
And I would,
I would say definitely not.
There's a lot of consequences that can
occur when you're sick,
when you already have this type of
damage where your immune system has been
activated.
I mean,
you're getting.
So that's not just A.
I'm sorry to interrupt you,
but that's not just a wound that's
bleeding under the skin.
That's part of the thing that's
happening.
But in addition to that,
you're,
you've got all sorts of cellular changes
that are occurring.
You're getting,
you know,
like I said,
damage to the damage.
These astrocytes that are forming the
blood brain barrier and then you start
getting those,
they start dying and when they start
dying at dead cell,
you know,
in addition to the,
the Microglia,
the immune system in the brain getting
activated to try to plug up the damage.
It also,
as soon as you have cells dying,
which in a case like this,
when you're.
We've got massive damage.
It's happening on a huge scale.
These microglia,
they try to like eat up and get rid of
all the cellular debris.
I mean that's part of what they do their
program to do these.
They get activated when you have a bunch
of dead cells and they try to go eat
away this damage.
And the problem is,
is that when that starts to happen,
you're getting a starting a cycle of
neuroinflammation in the brain,
which is very bad.
And you know,
what happens even within like hours of
an injury like that is you start to get
accumulation of something called amyloid
Beta plaques in the brain.
So,
you know,
traumatic brain injury and Alzheimer's,
they have a lot in common in the sense
where,
you know,
traumatic brain injury is a massive
amount of damage and it's happening in
one instance or even just mild
repetitive injuries.
You may not get someone that has a
swollen head like mark,
but you know,
just taking repetitive blows to the
head.
Also,
you're causing your activating,
you know,
reactive oxygen species are causing
cells to die and you are activating the
immune system even with a mild injury.
And what happens is that,
um,
you know,
in addition to start activating this
immune system,
then this also causes the accumulation
of these amyloid Beta plaques accumulate
in the brain.
So amyloid Beta plaques is one of the
major pathologies associated with
Alzheimer's.
What happens is as we age,
we have a little bit of inflammation
going on in our brain.
Know we have cells dying.
We have,
you know,
this is,
this is a little bit by bit scale every
day.
And so by the time,
you know,
seven,
eight decades go by,
you know,
we've accumulated enough damage,
stuff starts getting messed up.
So amyloid Beta plaques,
they form outside of neurons in between
glial cells and neurons and what they
do.
If you can even Google amyloid Beta
plaques,
you'll see they form these little
plaques outside of the neurons and this
disrupts like glucose metabolism and
neurons and astrocytes.
It causes even more reactive oxygen
species to be generated.
So now you're generating even more and
more on a daily basis.
And the microglia cells,
the immune cells of the brain get
activated when there's a plaque just
like they do when there's a dead cell.
They're like,
oh my God,
what is this?
I need to get rid of it.
So they get activated.
They secrete proinflammatory cytokines.
They're doing all this firing,
firing and the trying to eat the plaques
and so you know that it causes this
vicious cycle of neuroinflammation where
then that causes more plugs to be
formed.
So you have.
It's a terrible,
terrible cycle of neuroinflammation.
This amyloid Beta plaques form in in
fighters and also in like NFL player
that they've looked at these plaques
that are in the brains and they've.
They've even shown by like pet scans
that they form immediately,
like within hours,
and this even happens in children that
have undergone trauma,
you know,
so there's something,
it's almost like the traumatic brain
injury is like accelerated aging,
like,
like it's just instead of seven decades,
boom,
it's like it's happening,
you know,
in an instant,
in like in the course of hours,
and then you keep it and then it causes
this huge cycle of neuroinflammation.
So in addition to that,
Tau tangles start to form.
This is another thing that happens in
response to the activation of these
microglia cells in the brain.
We're now you've got something like
inside your neuron,
you,
you've got a protein called tau and it's
really an important protein because
basically what it does is it's like it's
transporting cargo all like a down the
long Axon to the snapchat cleft where
neurotransmission occurs,
where do you form synopsis to learn
memory?
Those things are happening.
It's taking,
it's transporting lipids,
it's transporting glucose,
it's transporting mitochondria that,
you know,
need to get to that synaptic cleft to
produce energy.
Um,
so it's like,
it's,
you know,
it's transporting all this cargo to get
there to do all this really important
stuff for your brain to function.
But what happens is,
you know,
traumatic brain injury and also just
normal brain aging when you have this
activation of the immune system and
reactive oxygen species,
it causes this thing aggregate and it
screws up its function and now it can't
transport any of that cargo.
It's like the train became derailed.
It can't get there.
So now you can't get,
you know,
nutrients to the,
to the part of the neuron where it needs
to get.
You can't get Mitochondria there,
you know,
which are making energy.
And so you start to have things breaking
down.
You start to have synopses dying.
Um,
you know,
that's part of the reason.
So to neurons,
they,
when you learn something,
you form a synaptic connections between
the neurons.
And that's the whole purpose of neurons.
They,
they want to form connections with other
neurons.
And that's,
you know,
that's what they're there for.
And when you can't do that,
if there's not enough energy and it
starts breaking down,
the neurons have no purpose,
they,
they can't,
so they die.
And so this,
this causes brain atrophy.
And it happens,
you know,
in normal brain aging over the course of
several decades where you can look at an
Alzheimer's brain and it's just gotten
massive atrophy.
Well,
the same thing happens with traumatic
brain injury.
You know,
these people are,
are losing a lot of cells,
glial cells and neurons in their brain
and it's causing brain atrophy.
So,
you know,
these,
the accumulation of amyloid Beta and tau
tangles are two prominent features of
Alzheimer's that are disrupting all
sorts of,
there causing,
like I said,
Immuno Neuro inflammation.
They're causing a reactive oxygen
species to be generated and does it.
It causes a cycle where it just won't
stop because whenever there's an amyloid
plaque,
you activate more microglia,
the Microglia get activated and makes
more plaques.
You know.
So it's,
it's just this horrible cycle that
doesn't get broken and not something
that's,
that's really,
uh,
they found both of these things very
prominently in brains of people that
have undergone Tbi.
I have a question about repeated trauma.
So if you are in a fight and you get hit
and hurt and you get in trouble,
but you survive and then you make it to
the next round,
do the,
the impacts that you take after that,
are they even more devastating because
of the initial impact?
Yes.
So what happens is,
because of the initial,
the initial injury,
your cells and because of the,
the,
the production of reactive oxygen
species and inflammatory response and
these things that are happening,
that is all a stress to the cell.
So the cell is already stressed and when
a cell is stressed,
it is more susceptible to death.
Um,
this is,
this is kind of part of the mechanism by
which cancer cells are primed to die in
a sense where cancer cells are stressed
because all sorts of stuff is going
wrong in them and they are primed to
die.
Like they,
the cell is expressing what's called pro
apoptotic proteins in cells that are
proteins that are going to make the cell
die,
but the cancer cells found a way to
overcome that by expressing these
antiapoptotic proteins,
and so it's a good balance between,
okay,
how much do I have that's gonna make me
die or not make me die?
So that's happening when you have a
stressed cell from injury and then like
for example,
brain injury,
they're also,
you know,
the,
the reactive oxygen species causes those
cells to make more of those proteins
that are saying,
okay,
di Di di,
so they're already primed to die.
Even if they,
some of them die immediately,
but even the ones that haven't died
immediately,
they may not be dead because there's
enough of those ones that are saying,
no,
don't die,
don't die.
Yet.
There's enough of that protein there to
sort of balance it out.
But then when you take another stress
boom,
it just tips it.
It tips it towards death.
So stress plus stress is additive in
that stress can sensitize you to death.
Stress Plus stress will definitely cause
death.
So that's,
that's something that,
you know,
taking,
having repetitive injuries specimen,
especially in a short timeframe like
that,
um,
you know,
sensitizes them to death.
So plus it's also,
you know,
you're,
you're making more of these amyloid Beta
plaques in your brain,
you know,
these,
this is like,
like I said,
it's happening within our.
So like the more injury that's
happening,
the more this is occurring.
So it's,
it's really a nasty thing and I'm with
fighters just from watching the one
event that I went to.
I mean it was clear that Mo,
pretty much all of them were taking
injuries to the head.
Um,
and so something that people may not be
aware of.
When I say people,
I mean people in the mma community is
that there's something else that really
predisposes these fighters to nerve
degenerative diseases.
Um,
so there's,
they categorize them as there's
different ones like pugilistic dementia,
and then there's chronic traumatic
encephalopathy.
And these are all,
if you look pathologically,
they all have,
they all share characteristics with
Alzheimer's disease.
They all have these amyloid Beta plaques
that have accumulated in the brain.
They have Taupe,
protein aggregating,
there's,
you know,
inflammation,
massive atrophy happening because these
things caused cell death.
These are all very common in their
shared pathological features and all
these neurogenic diseases.
I'm not sure what exactly if they see,
if they can't call it Alzheimer's
because Alzheimer's is an age related
disease,
so it's like calling someone who's 45
and has massive amyloid plaques in their
brain and it's affecting their memory
and it's affecting their behavior.
Calling that Alzheimer's is kind of
weird because Alzheimer's,
just a limiting word.
Do you think you're winning because when
you're dealing with the exact same
situation but brought on by trauma?
I don't know.
I,
I.
it's hard for me to definitively say
that.
It's a speculation.
I think that looking at,
like I said,
I think these pugilistic dementia and
these chronic traumatic encephalopathy,
it's like Alzheimer's,
but on an accelerated rate and it
happened specifically as a consequence
to traumatic injury to the head.
I've seen it happen in a fight like I've
seen a guy be one way and then have a
fight and see noticeably diminished
ability to communicate.
Yes.
Yeah.
That's one of the features of lack of
oxygen to the brain because now you
can't have energy,
you know,
be energy's not being made to have,
to,
to facilitate neurotransmission and
memory,
like learning and things and
communication.
Like what happens when you have inner
injury is that everything gets diverted
to repair its energy.
You only make so much energy and you
know,
so it's a constant battle and this is
the same for people that are obese type
two diabetics,
whatever type of chronic injury that's
happening in the body,
gut inflammation,
you know,
there's,
there's a lot of energy that need that's
required to repair that injury.
And so it's,
it's,
it's energy gets diverted to repairing
that injury.
And what happens when you have all the
energy that the cells are making go to
repair well,
things that are,
you know,
normal function,
don't get it.
So your metabolism is kind of screwed
up.
You're thinking,
you know,
these things are,
it's like a,
a triage almost where you're triaging
this to the essential like I need to
repair this damage.
If I don't repair this damage,
I might die.
So it's like you're shutting the energy
to that repair process.
So things like short term memory,
communication,
all that sort of gets screwed up in a
way.
So that makes perfect sense that,
that would happen.
Yeah.
Because I've literally seen guys in,
um,
it's,
it's so nonscientific to judge them by
the standard because,
you know,
just my perceptions.
But I've seen a guy be one way and then
have a couple of really brutal fights
and then there's a noticeable dimness to
the way they look,
the way they talk.
They just,
there seems to be like a,
like a loss.
What timeframe are we talking about
here?
A couple months.
Yeah.
Wow.
So,
I mean they've,
they've been shown that this injury,
the acute effects that I was describing
in terms of like,
you know,
the immune system,
the immune cells in the brain,
the microglia getting aggravated and
amyloid Beta plaques forming and all
that stuff happens and they showed that
this continues to happen for months,
even years later,
even with just a single,
like traumatic brain injury.
So
one rough fight can potentially effect
of a person other than negative impacts.
Compounds
four years,
yes,
yes.
They have shown a dose dependent effect
in terms of even multiple mild traumatic
injuries they compound over years and
they cause pugilistic dementia.
They cause,
you know,
these types of neurodegenerative
diseases that are very,
very similar to Alzheimer's.
And something that I want to point out
that may predispose people to them more
is genetics.
So this is something that's very,
very similar to Alzheimer's as well.
There's,
there's,
so we have different variations of genes
and these are called polymorphisms.
Really all a polymorphism is it's,
it's a gene,
but it's like it's,
there's a slight variation in the
sequence of DNA and that slight
variation in the sequence of DNA can
change the function of that gene
somewhat.
Um,
I think if we were to really look deeply
at polymorphisms,
we'd find there's gotta be a selective
reason why we've acquired these sort of
changes.
Like there's gotta be an advantage.
The polymorphisms aren't mutations in
the sense where like a mutation is
random,
you know,
that just happens.
Polymorphisms are selected for and they
occur in a,
in a decent percent of the population.
So you know,
there seems to be like you can always
find,
even if the gene changes the gene in the
sense where it seems like it's not doing
something as well as it should be doing.
If we look hard enough,
we might find there's actually a reason
why there's sort of like a trade off,
right?
So anyway,
so gene polymorphisms or we've got,
you know,
these are very common ones.
People are always looking at things like
the breast cancer related genes like
Brca one,
Brca two,
where it's like,
Oh,
if you have a certain variation of this
gene,
you have a dramatic increase in possibly
getting breast cancer.
Well we've got a lot of different
variations in genes and one of them is
associated with a dramatic increased
risk for Alzheimer's disease.
It's an engine called [inaudible] and
this,
this gene is polymorphic in the sense
where there's actually multiple bearing
inside,
but there's three different isoforms of
it that are common in the human
population.
It's called [inaudible] two [inaudible],
three and April before.
And essentially what it's a,
it's a light bulb protein and it's,
it's made in the liver.
And also in the brain and the liver,
what it,
what its main function is.
It's actually transporting cholesterol
like dietary cholesterol and it's making
sure it gets to your cells that need it
and bringing it back to the liver to get
recycled.
So plays a very important role in
cholesterol.
Transport turns out in the brain,
in our astrocytes are astrocytes,
make cholesterol.
We have,
we produce apo e in the brain and it
plays a very important role in
transporting this cholesterol made from
astrocytes to neurons.
And it's it,
it's doing other things also involved
with amyloid Beta.
But the point is is that there are,
like I said,
there are three variations.
The main one is apo e three and that's
what the majority of population has.
So you get one every gene you have,
you get one copy from your mom and you
get one copy from your dad.
So you have two copies of every gene.
And so that's when an illegal is.
So most people have two copies of April,
we three,
which is good because it's considered
the normal one like but 25 percent of
the population has one illegal of April.
We four.
And so April we four,
so 25 percent.
That's one in four.
People just have the general population
has one of these illegals that they
either got from their and their dad.
People that have to.
So they got one from this.
It's much more rare.
It's like two percent of the population
actually have two copies of the apoe e
four.
So 25 percent of population has one copy
of April before.
And what happens is April we for
increases the risk of Alzheimer's by two
to three fold.
Okay.
So people that have April before have an
increased risk of just two to three
fold.
And this is recognizable in the DNA
tests.
So you could potentially scan athletes.
Yeah.
So I'm getting to that.
So exactly.
So people that are fighters that are,
or nfl players,
people that are any sort of trauma to
the brain,
if they're getting this,
you know,
as a part of their sports curriculum or
whatever,
those people that have won a but we for
so traumatic brain injury itself
increases the risk of Alzheimer's by two
to three fold,
just like people that don't have
traumatic brain injury but have this
April.
We for people that have Tbi and April
before increase their risk by like
tenfold.
So having just one Leo,
you'd have something,
you have a guy who's getting blows to
the head and he has an April before he's
had taken his risks from two to three
fold to tenfold to get.
Yes.
And we're talking 25 percent of the
population has this.
So they've shown,
they've shown they've done studies and
they've shown,
you know,
traumatic brain injury dramatically
increases the risk of neurodegenerative
disease.
It's also stroke people with a stroke,
stroke and have April before you're
talking about a tenfold increase risk of
having a neurodegenerative disease.
So the problem is,
is that you're having before is you
can't repair damage as well.
Uh,
you know,
when you're,
when you have damage that occurs,
you know,
there's a lot of repair mechanisms that
can happen so you can have what's called
like if you lose,
like the synapses that are formed
between the two neurons,
amyloid Beta screws that up,
but you can repair that damage by having
what's called neurite outgrowth.
So you grow new projections to that
neuron.
That's one way to repair the damage and
Aicpa we plays a very important role in
that because it brings cholesterol and
fatty acids to the neuron,
the membrane and that,
that's really important to be able to
grow new synopsis.
You need that April before doesn't do
that as well.
And also not only does April,
we've worn out do that as well.
There's also bad effects.
April we for itself,
um,
is,
it's the polymorphism that happens,
it changes the structure of it.
And so it's like getting degraded a lot
so you don't have enough of a around and
it chops it up and starts aggregating
and doing bad stuff itself.
So it's like,
it's just terrible because what happens
when you have Tbi,
when you have an injury,
the brain actually increases a bowie
because it's like,
oh,
I got to repair some damage,
but if you have that April week four,
it's increasing the bad part.
It's increasing,
you know,
the bad stuff.
So you can actually test for this,
this variant using 23 and me for
example.
So I actually recently did a,
did a 23 and me test.
It's $99 and you spit and like a little
tube and you send it off to the,
to the 23 and me and they,
you know,
isolate Dna from your saliva and then
they look for very common polymorphisms.
So they look for April,
we,
they look for Parkinson's related ones
are in cancer and all that.
So,
uh,
you know,
unfortunately the FDA shut down part of
their ability to,
to inform you whether or not you have.
Yeah.
So that happened recently.
I think it was sort of a consequence to
Angelina Jolie getting her boobs cut off
essentially.
Yeah.
So was that misinformed what she did?
Um,
so I'm unfortunately,
I haven't really read exactly how
everything went down.
I just know that she did 23 and me and,
you know,
found out she had some,
she had a polymorphism and one of the
genes,
but she didn't have cancer.
No,
no.
So yeah,
so that's a pro.
I think that sort of precipitated the
FDA.
So the way they test for these genes is
by something called PCR and it's,
it's,
it's not infallible,
so you can,
you know,
they can give you back your results and
say oh look,
you've got this polymorphism is
associated with x disease,
which increases your risk for cancer by
tenfold and it could have just spend a
little air in the methods.
So,
you know,
it's not like a full proof proof
technique.
And I think that's also part of the
problem where it's like you're giving
people back this genetic data and it's
like they're taking it very seriously
and obviously taking,
going to extreme measures to do things,
you know,
like,
like getting their boobs removed.
Um,
but you still can 23 enemies not shut
down like you can.
Like I did it when they were already
unable to give you,
I'm tell you exactly what polymorphisms
you have.
Well,
I'm a scientist so I didn't really care
because they'd give you the raw data and
I can actually go through the raw data,
which I did and see what polymorphisms I
have and I found out that I actually
have one illegal of April before.
So,
so funny because it's really the only,
the only gene I cared about,
like all the other stuff.
Like I,
I did 23 in me because I was terrified
of having April before and um,
so I have it and if it turns out my dad
gave it to me and my dad has it.
So,
uh,
you know,
like I said,
having a.
But we for just one to Lille of it is
already you have a two to three fold
increase risk for Alzheimer's.
If you look at people with Alzheimer's,
between 65 and 80 percent of them have
one,
we'll have eight.
But we've for a.
So basically any person walking around
with one Leo has about a 30 percent risk
of getting Alzheimer's.
And it really,
really has to do with your,
your environment,
the way you interact with,
with your environment,
that that's going to shift you either
into getting it or not.
In what way?
Multiple ways.
Um,
so,
you know,
the,
the April before is,
like I said,
it's not working well and one of the
ways.
So amyloid Beta plaques building up in
the brain,
whether you're talking about at an
exponential rate because of injury,
traumatic injury to the brain.
We're talking about just normal brain
aging decades and decades and decades.
There's April,
we plays an important role in taking
that amyloid Beta that's built up and
bringing it to get degraded.
It gets rid of it.
But if you have ap,
we for it,
it just for some reason can't bind to
the,
a Beta plaque as well.
And so it can't remove it.
So you're,
you're talking about people that are not
only accumulating more of it because,
uh,
you know,
of other things that we for is doing,
but they can't remove it as well.
So you know,
people that have to April,
we three's,
they've got a better mechanism of
removing that amyloid Beta.
Well,
there's another way you can remove
amyloid Beta from the brain and that's
from getting sleep.
I'm literally so sleep when you sleep,
uh,
what happens is your brain actually
swells because cerebral spinal fluid
gets pushed up into the brain.
Your brain,
you have this whole glymphatic system,
you lymph vessels and things that are
surrounding neurons and astrocytes and
cerebral spinal fluid gets pushed into
the brain when you sleep and it
literally physically pushes out amyloid
Beta plaques.
It removes amyloid Beta plaques and
other dead debris.
Things like that just trashed.
That's building up in the brain.
Um,
and this is happening when you sleep.
So if you don't sleep,
if you're not getting enough sleep,
then you know,
people have this April we three,
that's another way they can clear it out
of the brain.
But me,
I really need to make sure I get enough
sleep because,
you know,
I don't have that other repair mechanism
to get rid of the amyloid Beta plaques.
Has there been anything else?
Does it meditation or anything along
those lines?
Um,
in terms of the glymphatic system,
I don't think that,
you know,
that seems to be a unique feature to
sleep.
Um,
something that's happening when your,
you know,
especially particularly in when you're
in rem sleep.
Um,
but you know why it's,
it's rem sleep is triggering it.
Yeah.
No,
this is a new relatively new finding and
I think we're going to in this decade.
Oh yeah,
like new as in just a couple of years
ago.
So it sounds so fascinating.
There's something so significant and
important is 2012,
right?
It's,
there's,
the human brain is very complicated and
there's lots of little,
you know,
people that are doing research.
They're looking at just little tiny
aspect of this and this little,
you know,
because there's so many little details
that you have to sort of interrogate to
figure things out and how they're
working.
But the glymphatic system is something
that's really cool because it gives a
mechanistic explanation as to why.
Another reason why sleep is so
important now.
Does nutrition play any part in your
brain's ability to do this or to do to
mitigate this issue?
Yeah,
so there's.
I mean nutrition plays a huge factor.
I mean if you look at people that are
obese,
you know,
and slash or insulin resistance type two
diabetic,
these people also have an increased risk
for Alzheimer's disease and they have an
increased risk for a lot of age related
disease.
I mean they're,
it's like they're accelerating their
aging process in general,
but the fact that they also have an
increased risk for Alzheimer's disease,
Parkinson's is very,
you know,
it's interesting because it suggests
something about not having the right
diet is also involved.
And there's multiple things going on
here and you know,
I can't figure all of them out,
but you know,
part,
part of the reason is they've shown that
inflammation,
so obesity,
you've got chronic inflammation going on
also with type two diabetics and that
inflammation actually causes a secretion
of like proinflammatory cytokines,
which are,
you know,
the activate the immune system,
because that's what happens when the
body is like,
wait,
something's here.
That's not supposed to be.
Get rid of it and this is the same thing
that happens in the brain that causes
the amyloid Beta plaques to start
getting built up.
Well,
those things cross over at the blood
brain barrier,
inflammatory cytokines,
crossover,
get into the brain and start causing
neuroinflammation.
So it's really like they've even shown
like if you inject,
you can inject people with endotoxin.
Endotoxin is what's like a part of the
bacterial cell wall.
It's released,
you know,
when bacteria are dying and it happens
in the gut a lot,
but it causes massive inflammation and
you can inject people with endotoxin and
it causes learning and memory deficits
and it causes depressive symptoms.
Um,
also you can inject them with a pro
inflammatory cytokines,
interferon.
And that interferon also causes
depressive symptoms because you know,
inflammation is being more and more
linked to depression as well.
But also inflammation in the brain is
actually causing the aggregation of
these amyloid Beta plaques to occur.
So that's very interesting.
How literally inflammation in your body,
in your gut,
you know,
in the,
in the peripheral part of your body,
your body can affect your brain.
It's your will.
There's
I there been sorted in revenue again,
but it haven't.
There been some recent studies that have
shown that the gut bacteria have kids
that have Alzheimer's.
Is,
is usually an issue that a lot of
children that have Alzheimer's also have
issues with gut bacteria like autism or.
What did I say?
Alzheimer's.
I'm sorry.
Yeah,
autism.
We really,
you know what I'm saying?
Literally where's it coming out?
Maybe I've been hitting the head too
many times.
Um,
but yeah,
autism spectrum disorders and even
asperger's that there's been some sort
of a connection to gut bacteria.
Yeah,
yeah,
definitely.
I mean these people with autism do have
a lot of inflammation in their gut and
you know,
having inflammation in your gut,
what's going to happen?
It's going to get into your brain and
it's going to cause neuro inflammation
in your brain.
And another thing that inflammation in
the brain does is it activates,
you know,
the.
You've got prostoglandins that are being
generated specifically eat two series
prostoglandins.
And the reason why that's bad in the
brain is because generating [inaudible]
series prostoglandins inhibits the
brain's ability to release serotonin.
So you basically can't release serotonin
from like a presynaptic neuron,
which is important and you want it,
you need to release Serotonin,
serotonin during a lot of things in
addition to regulating mood,
regulating behavior,
regulating impulsive behavior,
things like that,
social behavior,
but you know this,
this inflammation that gets into the
brain literally stop Serotonin from
being released from the brain by,
by inhibiting this,
this.
Sorry,
by activating the two series and they've
even shown like that study I was talking
about people where they injected a pro
inflammatory cytokine and they bake.
They had came down with depressive
symptoms if they gave those people epa
like a very high dose of EPA.
So I cone up Penta eicosapentaenoic
acid,
which is one of the Omega Threes that
that mitigated the depressive symptoms
like they didn't get the depressive
symptoms because I think that what's
happening is that inflammation is
causing.
One thing that EPA does very potent and
potently inhibits the generation of
approximate sentence.
So in that way,
gut bacteria,
especially taking in in the form of
probiotics is probably a very important
part of the human diet that is widely
ignored by a lot of people,
right?
Yeah.
Acidophilus.
You're drinking Kombucha here.
I love,
I love my Kombucha.
But what I said to you that this is the
computer that's watered down so that it
meets the whole food standards.
No,
I had no idea that this.
Did you get this at whole foods?
The one up the street.
They have the regular stuff too.
You gotta know what bottle to get and
you need to have a license,
like a driver's license.
It shows you're over 21,
but it's only one half of one percent.
That's the cutoff.
If it's more than one half of one
percent alcohol by volume,
then you have to have.
It has to have to have a liquor license
to sell it,
which is preposterous.
You can't get drunk off of it.
No,
I had no idea that this was watered
down.
But yes,
you know,
probiotics are very important.
Um,
you know,
you've,
you want.
So probiotics are doing things like
generating lactic acid,
which are does a lot of things.
One is it's killing off these pathogenic
bacteria that can't live in an acidic
environment in the gut,
but also like I mentioned,
lactate,
you know,
lactates also can be used by
Mitochondria.
So you know,
you're talking about giving a source of
energy for your Mitochondria,
you know,
so that you can,
it an important component of not having
a lot of gut inflammation is,
yes,
the balance between pro biotics and,
and the pathogenic bacteria.
But it's also maintaining that gut
barrier because you've got a lot of
immune cells in your gut,
you know,
they're there because you don't want to
eat something bad and you know,
kill you.
So they're there and they're ready to,
you know,
fight off anything that's potentially
pathogenic.
So they have a purpose of being there.
The way they don't continually,
continually,
uh,
start fighting off things is because
there's a barrier which is basically a
mucous,
um,
it's called mucin and your gut cells
secrete it.
And this mucin is important for
separating the immune cells in your gut
from the bacteria.
Because when that mucin gets broken
down,
then your immune cells are exposed to
bacteria which are supposed to be in
your gut,
and they're like,
oh,
bacteria.
And they start firing all these
cytokines and you get,
you start to get inflammation,
which then breaks down the gut barrier
more and it causes the same sort of
cycle that I was talking about in the
brain.
You know,
this sort of cycles going on can happen
in the gut as well.
So things like eating a lot of sugar,
you know,
like can literally break down the Mucin,
uh,
you know,
so it's like that's having that chronic
inflammation is I'm doing a lot of
things.
So having the right balance of bacteria
is one thing that's good,
but also making sure that you're eating
the right diet to make sure that you're,
you know,
you're giving yourself the right energy
they need to,
to do things that they're supposed to
do.
Like if it's,
if we're talking about the gut making,
Mucin and sugar actually fuels bad
bacteria in the gut as well,
right?
Yeah.
A sugar does feel bad bacteria in the
gut.
So a lot of the bad bacteria in the gut
like to get them some sugar.
So then you're talking about having
overgrowth of the bad bacteria,
you know,
so it's,
there's a lot weakens your immune
system.
Yes.
Sugar is significant.
Immune system weakening inflammation in
general.
I mean,
I think that also has a lot to do with,
if you think about having,
you know,
a breakdown of the gut barrier and all
this pathogenic bacteria which also
break down the gut,
like that's what they do also.
Um,
a lot of energy gets spent towards
fixing that,
oh my God,
I got to fix that.
I got to repair this.
And that takes away from brain phone.
That takes away from Brent Stage Immune
function because now you know,
you're all,
the energy's going towards the gut to
repair this chronic damage that's also
happening.
And now you're,
your immune systems.
Don't you know when,
when you're fighting off a disease,
when you're fighting off a pathogenic,
you know,
whether it's viral or bacterial or
whatever,
like that requires a massive amount of
energy,
massive amount of energy.
That's an energy consuming process.
So it's a matter of triaging this energy
to the right place.
It's like,
okay,
well,
you know,
if I,
if my guts really healthy,
I'm not inflamed,
I have a good diet,
I'm getting my micronutrients,
I'm not eating a bunch of sugary crap,
you know,
the refined carbohydrates and things
like that.
Then you know,
your,
you don't have all this chronic damage
happening that you,
your,
your energy is constantly.
It's like a drain,
an energy drain.
It just keeps getting sucked into it and
that,
you know,
that affects all sorts of other
functions in the body.
So,
uh,
and there's other explanations,
but I like to think about it that way in
terms of like a triaging of energy
because it really just makes a lot of
sense from an energetic standpoint.
Looking at how energetically consuming
I'm fighting off diseases and how
energetically consuming repair is.
And people that are obese or type two
diabetic,
they're in a constant repair state
constant.
So it's,
a lot of it is poor energy management
because of your diet,
because your energy is being taken away
to a bunch of functions that you
wouldn't order ordinarily needed for if
your diet was good.
Exactly,
exactly.
Like,
um,
it's really interesting the lab that I,
uh,
that I work in.
I'm at Children's Hospital in Oakland.
We work with a lot of insulin resistant,
obese children,
um,
but we're also doing research on
adolescents and even some of the parents
of these children which are also obese,
insulin resistant.
Um,
and uh,
some of my colleagues in my lab have
developed a,
like a nutrient bar,
they call it the core rebar and the
nutrient.
It's like a micronutrient dense bar
where it has,
you know,
all sorts of vitamins and minerals and
vitamin D and fiber has some
polyphenols.
It has.
Dha has just a bunch of good stuff
instead of taking a bunch of vitamins,
it's all in like a matrix with fiber and
stuff so that things are absorbed better
and digested.
And,
um,
you know,
my,
my colleagues,
I haven't been directly involved in this
research because I look more at things
like dna damage,
but what,
what my colleagues have found is that
giving these obese people,
whether we're talking about children or
adolescents,
adults giving them this micronutrient
bar,
um,
if you compare like giving it to a lean
person and you don't have them change
their diet at all,
it's like,
you know,
do what you're going to do,
eat,
eat what you're going to eat.
But here,
take this twice a day on top of that.
Um,
what we find is that one publication
that was done on lean people,
lean people like immediately it,
their hdl goes up,
you know,
things start happening.
They make more glutathione,
like all these positive changes occur,
but obese people,
it takes a lot longer to happen.
Like it takes a couple of weeks.
Whereas I actually takes even more than
that.
Um,
I don't remember the exact amount of
time,
but,
uh,
it,
it takes longer to happen.
We think it takes longer because these
people first,
all that energy that,
you know,
this stuff,
the micronutrients,
all these things,
it's,
it's being shunted towards fixing,
fixing,
and eventually as they start to fix,
then you start to see little changes
happening.
But it doesn't happen right away.
Like it happens in people that are
healthy and I use lean as a marker for
healthy.
I mean,
it's not entirely accurate,
accurate,
but generally speaking,
when exactly relatively speaking,
glutosiome do you take glutathione
supplement?
Um,
no,
so that actually I wanted to talk about
some of the possible,
you know,
Tbi,
we're talking about traumatic brain
injury and I talked about all this
terrible stuff,
but there are things that can be done to
help.
Um,
and glutathione is interesting because,
so glutathione is,
it's one of the major antioxidant in the
brain,
which is why it's very important,
um,
you know,
as,
as for for brain aging in general,
and it's all been associated with a lot
of studies in terms of the more
glutathione in the brain,
you know,
decreased Alzheimer's,
decreased damage in the brain going on.
Um,
you know,
glutathione is just basically three
amino acids that are together and it's
glutamic acid,
glycine,
and I think assisting,
so our body makes this inside of
ourselves.
We make it,
we have an enzyme called Glutathione
synthase and that enzyme takes those
amino acids and puts it together.
And then once we have glutathione,
we have other enzymes that are able to
use glutathione as a potent antioxidant.
Glutathione Peroxidase,
for example,
this is another enzyme that uses that
glutathione to prevent that reactive
oxygen species damage I was talking
about that happens like one of the early
events with traumatic brain injury and
it's also one of the early damaging
events that happens just with normal
brain aging,
which is happening all the time.
We're making it right now in our brains.
Um,
so,
uh,
having gludethyon in the brain is really
good and there's different enzymes that
use it.
So Glutathione Peroxidase,
we'll use glutathione to,
um,
to basically reduce that oxidative
damage so it can't damage the neuron or
astrocyte or whatever,
you know,
cell type that it comes in contact with.
Um,
the problem is that with age,
we decrease the expression of
glutathione related genes and what that
means is,
you know,
you have genes in your body and
sometimes they can be expression just
means you make more of it.
So when you're,
when it's being expressed,
you're making more of it.
So that's a thing.
As we age,
we decrease the expression,
so like everything,
things fall apart and we don't make as
much of these glutathione related genes.
Um,
the thing with glutathione is you can't
because it's made in ourselves.
There's no transport mechanism to get
glutathione into the cell,
like you know,
you,
you can transport it in immuno acids and
the amino acids.
Then this glutathione synthase uses
those to make it in the cell,
but there's no transport mechanism for
glutamic acid,
glycine and sustained together to get
in.
And,
you know,
you can't just,
cells have a transport mechanism to get
stuff inside.
It's a regulated process.
Um,
so taking glutathione orally a is sort
of pointless.
Not to mention the fact that the guy
isn't going to absorb it,
either.
It gets broken apart.
Um,
there is lyposomal glutathione.
Yeah,
so Lyposomal,
Glutathione,
um,
anything that's Lyposomal can bypass a
lot of these transport mechanisms just
based on,
you know,
the way.
So first of all,
liposomes can be absorbed by the gut but
also they can get into cells because a
lyposomal is basically like,
you know,
it's like a little liquid that has a
fascial liquid by layer and it has
whatever it has inside of it,
in this case,
glutathione which is soluble and it
fuses with the Lipid biolayer of the
cell membrane and basically just gets
taken up.
And so then whatever's inside of it goes
into the cell.
They've shown in.
I've looked for studies to see,
you know,
lyposomal supplemental Lyposomal
Glutathione.
Like how I like is it getting into
tissue,
is it getting into the brain,
for example,
because that's important and I haven't
found a lot of studies.
I found one study that showed in rabbits
that were given oral glutathione,
oral liposomal glutathione were able to
increase the glutathione levels in their
brain,
in their heart and also in the liver.
But they were given a massive dose.
Like they were given 400 milligrams.
And there are about 11 pounds,
so that's like six grams for like 180
pound man.
Four hundred milligrams in the physical
form.
Like what would you see?
Is it,
would it be,
how many teaspoons would that be for
row?
Oh,
I don't.
I don't know.
I mean you'd have to look at.
I think if it's in a teaspoon,
it tells you the like milligram content
per teaspoon.
I did look up online to see because I
was like,
I got to gave me some of this.
And um,
the problem is that most of the
liposomal glutathione is really
expensive and it's like between 100
milligrams and 400 milligrams per dose,
per teaspoon or per capsule,
whatever they do to a rabbit.
They gave write a law.
But a rabbit weighs 11 pounds.
Swallows it too.
Aren't you supposed to hold it in your
mouth?
Under your tongue.
Now they're,
they,
they enjoy.
They give it to the,
to the rabbit.
Like they inject it in their mouth.
Yeah.
And the way I've been told to take the
lyposomal glutathione is to Tuck it
under your tongue or shorter under your
tongue,
holding your mouth for 30 seconds and
then swallow it.
Does that make any sense at all?
And now I have no idea how that,
what that would do,
but the idea of being.
Sorry,
go ahead.
No,
I mean the point is,
is that you supplement like Lyposomal
Glutathione,
maybe actually you may be getting it
into your brain.
It's just a matter of how much is it
they didn't do a dose response in that
study and if it wasn't so darn
expensive,
there's other ways to increase
glutathione.
But here's the thing.
So taking supplemental glutathione in
the form of Lyposomal Glutathione,
of course,
any other supplemental glutathione is
just useless.
Yeah,
it's useless pill form.
Nothing.
I think they have liposome.
You can have it in pill form with
letrozole.
Yeah.
But it just has to be.
Light is almost the point,
right?
Yeah.
If it's not lyposomal then you're not
even getting it passed the gut let alone
into the cell.
So,
um,
but the other thing is,
is that,
okay,
so here's the thing,
your suppliers,
your yourselves with this lyposomal
glutathione,
but the thing is,
is that the enzyme that uses
glutathione,
glutathione peroxidase and these other
enzymes,
they decreased with age.
So while you're bypassing the,
you know,
the decrease in the expression of
Glutathione synthase,
which is what makes glutathione,
you're not bypassing the decrease in
expression of this enzyme that uses it,
that's using gludethyon to do its thing.
So that's also important and there's
other ways that you can actually
increase glutathione.
But just interestingly,
I came across a study recently,
like 2014,
very late,
I think it was even just a couple months
ago.
It was,
um,
a traumatic brain injury study where
they basically took mice and they
induced traumatic brain injury by like
putting pressure on their brain.
And what happens is they noticed that
the blood brain barrier is compromised.
All those things that I was talking
about happens.
Water's flowing into the brain and saw
you and all that and activation of
immune function.
All that stuff's happening.
What they found was that if they put
glutathione,
they actually,
because I did a pressure now schools are
much thinner than a human's goals are
and if they did a pressure room to the
mouse school,
there was like a little tiny crack in
the skull and they could put glutathione
on top topically where the crack is and
it would get through into the brain and
what they found was that if they did it
within three hours of the injury,
they,
they abrogated like 70 percent of the
cell death.
That happens.
It was amazing,
but it was a three hour time window
because there will be done the humans.
So I was wondering,
well,
so the thing that's what got me on this
whole episomal trail,
I was like,
well we can't.
First of all,
we don't even know anything about the
human skull.
I mean we know about it,
but we don't know whether or not you can
put something topically after a
traumatic injury and if it's going to
get in there doing those studies.
Now,
because this was.
This was actually a new discovery where
it's like,
Oh wow,
you can
actually get through the skull and get
into the,
at least under an injury's type
situation.
So the idea would be that you would
inject something into the skin on the
scalp.
Um,
I don't know if they injected it,
but yeah,
that go under the French,
the end of the needle.
But whether or not that can be done in
humans,
I don't know.
Like I said,
I mean,
first of all,
humans have a much thicker skull then
then.
So.
Right.
But,
um,
so they're going to be testing that.
But the other thing is,
is like,
okay,
well can you.
The key part of this study and my mind
was they inhibited that reactive oxygen
species,
which is the instigator of this whole
cascade,
this neuroinflammatory,
if they went downstream and try to
inhibit,
inhibit inflammation,
it didn't have the effect because those
things were already activated.
You already had sell dead cells because
it's the reactive oxygen species
starting it and causing the cell death.
And that was how they were able to
prevent like 70 percent of the cell
death by giving that topical
Glutathione.
So,
uh,
that was,
it was like,
wow,
well we've got to figure out how to do
that.
Yeah,
exactly.
And so,
uh,
the,
there's other ways you can increase
glutathione.
The light is almost one.
I don't know how robust,
like I said,
with that one study in rabbits,
massive amount.
We're talking about like for 180 pound
man.
And I don't even know how much some of
these MMA fighters were.
They probably weighed more than that.
But you know,
180 pound man,
he's talking about six grams of
Liposomal Glutathione,
which is a lot significant amount.
I mean,
considering how much,
how costly is,
it's just not economically feasible in
my mind on these.
The holding it under the tongue I've
seen will be 12 of.
That's okay.
Make sense?
It'd be 12 people.
It's sublingual that people do that to
bypass the whole stomach acid thing.
But you know,
I don't know,
maybe there's something I just don't
know about with the Liposomal
Glutathione.
Sublingual means what,
what does that actually mean?
That means holding it in under the
tongue is just the distribution method.
Right?
So to use lyposomal and use it in a
sublingual way to Tuck in under.
Does that make any sense?
Would it go into your blood that way?
Um,
I mean,
I don't know why it would be any
different than swallowing it,
but don't waste my time.
I would just be not thinking about
something that's obvious to me or,
or it's just always time.
There've been studies on that light bulb
will be 12 taken sublingually.
I haven't really read any.
There may have been studies on that,
but I haven't,
I haven't looked in the literature of
that.
I'll look it up right now.
Yeah.
So the other ways to increase.
So like I mentioned,
so there's,
there's genes that are glutathione
related genes and you can increase the
expression of those genes were right
away.
Sublingual lyposomal glutathione shows
up in the first thing that you,
uh,
you google.
If you Google sublingual lyposomal
glutathione is the first thing that pops
up in Google.
Yeah.
Well,
that's something I can certainly read
about,
but I just off the top of my head,
can't think of why that would be more
effective at getting into yourself
saying right here,
the only way to get significant amounts
into your body is with lyposomal
glutathione supplements.
Uh,
either ivy or injection is the other
way.
Yeah.
Injections another way.
And that all obviously bypasses the
whole intestinal absorption thing.
Yeah.
So what's interesting is they've done so
other ways to increase glutathione would
be,
for example,
a turmeric.
Turmeric.
Turmeric,
yeah.
I use that stuff.
That's awesome.
Well,
they've shown.
So the,
there,
there's two different bioactive
components in it.
One is the curcumin and that has.
What that does,
curcumin is,
first of all,
it's awesome.
It gets into the brain and it's an anti,
has antioxidant activity itself aside
from Gludethyon,
but it also increases the expression of
all the good design related genes.
So it turns on Glutathione Peroxidase,
glutathione synthase,
and another gene called Glutathione
reductase,
which actually recycles glutathione
that's already been used or oxidized,
which is really cool because now you're
talking about ramping up the whole
glutathione system.
Like all of it,
and,
and this curcumin does this.
Um,
and so there was a,
they've done studies in mice where
they've done know,
Tbi related studies for traumatic brain
injury where they've,
they've given them,
they did intravenous and because of the,
the effects of,
you know,
you,
you basically metabolize curcumin
immediately.
Um,
it's like 40 minutes to an hour to say
curcumin or cirque human.
I always Kirk Hubert human.
Yeah.
I know I've said it wrong.
What do you usually say?
Human.
Oh,
now I think it's curcumin.
Yeah.
Just read it and try to understand.
Oh really?
Wow.
So America have heard,
but the actual turmeric to Merck termer
tumor,
I think there's an art.
She,
you are turmeric.
Turmeric.
Yeah.
But whatever.
It's not important to get good stuff.
Yeah.
It's like curries,
you know,
people using the curries,
but it's sort of antiinflammatories not
only anti-inflammatory,
it inhibits the activation of nf kappa
b,
which is like this gene that turns on a
whole variety of different genes
involved in inflammation.
So it's like blunting the whole
inflammatory cascade and it activates
all the glutathione genes.
And on top of that,
it has antioxidant activity itself,
so it's like,
you know,
it's just like a triple whammy.
So it's really cool.
So curcumin is probably way better than
taking lyposomal glutathione,
I don't know,
because maybe in synergistic for
synergistic.
But the thing with Kirk curcumin is that
it is also rapidly metabolized because
it's a form it says,
you know,
biotic,
which means it's not a vitamin or a
mineral,
it's something foreign to the body,
you know,
polyphenols,
EGC,
gds from green tea,
all these things were the same.
A lot of herbal academia,
these are what are called xenobiotics.
And what happens when you take a
xenobiotic is it activates this whole
pathway in the liver,
which is like the liver is like,
oh,
there's this foreign thing in my body
that's not supposed to be here.
It's not a vitamin,
it's not a mineral.
Okay,
I need to get rid of it.
So it metabolize it's detoxifying,
whatever.
So,
um,
it gets metabolized rapidly.
But there's something in black pepper
called piperine.
Piperine.
Yeah.
That inhibits the nobody xenobiotic
metabolism.
So it's been shown in humans that if you
give a coworker curcumin and piperine
that you can increase the
bioavailability of curcumin by 2000
percent in humans,
which is pretty significant.
And so that's kind of cool because I'm
like,
oh,
well of course I ordered some curcumin
with piperine and a tick for myself
because I've got April before and it's
just a really good thing.
Um,
but with traumatic brain injury they've
shown that,
you know,
if they gave it to a,
to mice to do it intravenously and they
give them like a really high dose,
it prevents,
you know,
the whole inflammatory response to the
edema.
Intercranial pressure,
like all that stuff is dramatically
improved.
And this is again,
it's like a time window where it was
like,
you know,
a few hours after the trauma,
after the trauma.
So it's,
you know,
but I think maybe even before,
if you're already,
if you already have it in your system,
you know,
the question is how much is it,
is it going to like,
you know,
prevent the acute immediate thing.
I don't know to what degree,
but at least at the very least taking it
every day,
you're talking about inhibiting some of
that neuroinflammatory cycle,
that cycle.
That's really,
you know,
vicious because once you have the
plaques forum,
which happens within hours after injury,
then you're talking about,
you know,
it activating the whole cycle where it
causes more and more years and years and
years.
So there's no negative repercussions to
take my other stuffing their.
Yeah.
So in that study where they increased
the bioavailability by 2000 percent,
there was no adverse side effects.
However,
since piperine inhibits xenobiotic
metabolism,
full force,
like you know,
it's,
it's inhibiting this very generalized
pathway that's used to detoxify and get
rid of all sorts of foreign things.
Like even drugs like antibiotics,
whatever,
you know,
your stands,
whatever you take.
I'm so,
there is a concern like in my mind,
I haven't done a lot of reading on this,
you know,
to see what's out there in literature,
but just from my understanding of the
mechanism,
I think it's you don't want to go crazy
because it's like if you're taking a
bunch other stuff because it's going to
increase the,
the half life of all sorts of,
you know,
other xenobiotics which are just like I
said,
a lot of different herbal things or you
know,
things like curcumin and UGC,
all that stuff.
So there's always that potential.
It's like,
well what else are you taking?
Are you increasing the half life of that
too by taking this piperine with it and
what does that doing?
So that's it.
You should definitely be cautious in
that,
in that respect.
But don't take too much of it.
But yet I haven't seen too much of it.
Like I know when I did some searching
for like the Tumeric,
but the thing is is that I like the
tumeric and not just the curcumin
because there's another compound in
turmeric called tomorrow and aromatic
turnaround and a study just came out
like a couple of months ago on this
where it's actually,
it does.
It does a lot of the same things that
the curcumin does and that it inhibits
inflammation,
but it does something in addition to
that,
it actually repairs brain damage because
it causes the proliferation of neural
stem cells in your brain.
So I know it's like.
And it was very robust.
There's,
there's two regions of the brain that
you can actually.
You have neuro stem cells,
which means you can make new neurons.
You've damaged neurons,
neurons have died,
you know,
you want to replace those neurons and
there's two regions of the brain that
can do that.
The sub brand tricolor zone and the
dentate gyrus.
And so tomorrow actually causes the
polyphony ration of neural stem cells in
the sub ventricular zone.
And to some degree when they're giving
these mice.
I can't recall off the top of my head
the dose,
but they were giving him a pretty high
dose and what they found was that it
increased the proliferation of them by
like,
you know,
60 percent,
which is pretty significant.
A part of the problem with age is that,
uh,
these neuro stem cells,
they start to proliferate less and as
they start to proliferate less than you
have less of them being made and you
also have less a new neurons being made.
So net less neurogenesis.
So if you think about in the context of
someone who's undergone a traumatic
brain injury,
they have undergone,
they've had massive amounts of cell
death occurring from that reactive
oxygen species from that inflammation.
You know,
they've lost neurons.
That's,
that's,
that's a fact.
So if you can have something that's
boosting the proliferation of their
neuro stem cells,
that's a great thing.
It's not just a great thing for people
that have had an injury.
It's a great thing for just normal brain
aging.
Um,
I think it's also a great thing for
people that are susceptible to
neurogenic diseases like myself,
because I have one of these April,
we four wheels,
you know,
so I'm,
I've got to be really careful because I
can't repair damage as well.
If I can make sure I grow new neurons,
then you know,
that's,
that's a good thing.
I didn't know there was anything that
you could eat.
The could help grow new neurons.
I'd never heard of it.
Yeah.
So tomorrow is,
stimulates,
stimulates the,
of
the neuro stem cells in the suburban
Tricolor zone.
Um,
this,
this study was really came out like less
than two months ago.
That's incredible.
It's pretty incredible.
Yeah.
I'm so you could get smarter for meeting
today.
They did get smarter.
They had improvements.
Now,
I mean take this with a grain of salt in
the sense where it's like the whole
bioavailability thing and humans and how
much are we.
That's always the issue.
It's like,
okay,
well they're giving mount mice,
you know,
a much higher dose and you know,
so that it's like bypassing,
first of all they're injecting it in
some cases so it's bypassing the whole
getting absorbed.
But the fact that it occurs is hopeful
because it's like,
well eventually we'll find a way to
overcome some of the bioavailability
issues,
which,
you know,
we kind of are.
So is the Bio availability issue
mitigated it all by a large dose is
taking,
what do you recommend as a dose?
Like a thousand milligram pills or what
I have of turmeric?
Well in the case of the Mouse Studies,
it's mitigated by a large dose that's
given intravenously.
So I need to start shooting.
So you don't have,
but how do you shoot up turmeric?
Yeah,
I,
you know,
I don't know.
I,
and,
and the question is they bought up your
book,
the suppository.
They have clinical trials that are,
they're doing now with people with
Alzheimer's or people that have dementia
early,
you know,
early dementia science.
They're doing this with a tumeric and I
hope they use piperine also are using
depositories or there might just,
I don't know,
I don't know what they're using because
a lot of studies have come out recently
in a different,
in different model organisms where
they've looked at worms and flies and
mice and they're and they have all these
different neurodegenerative,
you know,
sort of models where they look and study
this stuff and they find hands down this
tumeric is doing some cool shit.
Like it's,
it's awesome.
And these studies are the administering
it orally or the using injectables if
talking about mice then there's a lot of
them have been injectable and this is
where the studies are coming out.
So these aren't on humans yet,
but they did get smarter.
The people that they did it to,
that got smarter.
They did.
So the people and that,
those were mice.
The mice get smarter,
the mouse performed better on learning
and memory.
Yes,
yes.
Yes.
So,
but let's see,
what was the other.
There was another interesting thing
about the.
Oh,
I know what I wanted to bring up.
It was,
I got sort of sidetracked when I was
talking about the neural stem cells that
are in the brand tricolor zone.
What's really interesting about this is
that they,
um,
they readily go to the olfactory bulb,
no smell,
so their sense of smell is a good
predictor of Alzheimer's disease and
Parkinson's disease and even just all
caused mortality.
Like literally you can have decreased
sense of smell and you know,
it can be a good predictor of your next,
you know,
five year mortality.
Um,
and it's like,
why is this sense of smell such
a good predictor of,
you know,
people that are going to get Alzheimer's
soon.
Also people that may just die soon and
re we're finding out again,
just recently within the past couple of
months that the olfactory bulb requires
a constant supply of neural stem cells
because the olfactory neurons which are
in your factory bulb,
which is just right in front of your
brain.
Those neurons which are responsible for
smelling things,
you know,
and they send signals to the brain so
that you can,
you know,
experience it,
so to speak.
They require a constant supply of neural
stem cells,
which is coming from the sub ventricular
zone.
And so,
uh,
when you start to,
to,
to have that process diminish where you
can't supply those new stem cells to the
olfactory bulb,
your sense of smell goes away.
And so that's why also it's a predictor
of Alzheimer's because you're literally
losing the ability to know,
don't people are born with people are
born with a terrible sense of smell.
That doesn't mean that you don't,
that you're not making neural stem
cells.
So please don't freak out.
Like there's other reasons why you
cannot have a good sense of smell.
The reason this was impacting me right
now is because I know people who've been
knocked out and lost their sense of
smell.
Yeah.
So,
wow.
So that's,
um,
the,
uh,
the tomorrow and that was given to these
mindset,
improve their sense of smell and
improved.
Um,
you know,
there's,
this is,
there's another thing also with this
neuro stem cell.
I'm,
I've known for some time that this sense
of smell is a good predictor of
Alzheimer's.
But in just until I had,
I just didn't understand why and this
whole understanding the neuro stem cells
being having to replace it like
constantly.
So it's literally like marker.
It's like a marker for brain,
your brain's ability to repair damage in
your brain.
Um,
I remember last time I was on the
podcast,
you mentioned that study where they gave
young blood to old mice and they
essentially made them again,
well I'm going to bring this back to the
nose.
So I became very interested in that
study.
And so essentially what they found is
that there is something in the blood
that secreted in.
So it's in the plasma actually,
and it's called a growth differentiation
factor 11.
And it goes,
it's made.
It's made more readily in young blood.
So it decreases with age,
like everything does.
And what happens is this growth
differentiation factor 11 goes to the
brain,
goes to the muscle and it stimulates
stem cell proliferation and it does it
in the separate ventricular zone.
And so when they gave it,
like they did this,
when they did it in mice,
what they found was that the mouse,
the mice,
you know,
there are tissues were less age,
the only way you can reverse tissue
aging in that to that degree has got to
be related to stem cells because when
you already have all this damage,
like the only way you're going to repair
that damage is by replacing and
replenishing that population with new
cells.
And because as we age,
the ability to do that,
our stem cell,
the ability proliferation decreases and
all that stuff decreases.
We can't do it as well.
And also,
you know,
the more reactive oxygen species,
we get them more.
Those cells start dying.
So the fact that you know,
these tissues were able to reverse the
aging was really,
you know,
obviously indicative of stem cells when
they found was indeed this growth
differentiation factor is in the plasma.
More bits and young people and it's
causing the proliferation of neural stem
cells and the stubborn tricolor zone.
And also in muscle.
What they found was they could even
isolate that growth differentiation,
differentiation factor.
And you know,
inject it into old mice and you would
have the same effect,
which is really cool because that gives
hope for isolating it in for,
you know,
basically people using it as a source to
stimulate proliferation of stem cells.
And there's actually a clinical trial
that started this month at Stanford
where they are injecting plasma from
young individuals that are younger than
30 and they're giving them to people
with mild Alzheimer's,
older people with mild Alzheimer's and
they're going to check the,
the cognitive effects,
you know,
immediately after and also longterm.
So,
but the whole stem cell thing in the
nose.
And it's very interesting how it's like
the nose that stem cells,
neural stem cell,
more capacity to make more of them can
be,
you know,
you can see the status of that by your
sense of smell and the fact that you've
observed fighters that have had
decreased sense of smell that is
alarming.
Well,
there's one guy named Gary,
good rich.
He's a real veteran mixed martial arts
fighter who was around during the early
days of the UFC and he fought in k,
one.
He fought in pride.
He's like kind of a legendary mixed
martial arts character and he's dealing
with some pretty significant traumatic
brain injury now from,
from years and years of fighting,
and that's one of the issues that he had
and he lost his sense of smell and that
makes total sense what you're saying.
Yep.
I'm sorry to hear that.
You know,
I,
like I said,
the,
the April we,
fourth thing is something I think is
really,
really significant and I think that
yeah,
they've shown it with traumatic brain
injury from car accidents.
They've shown it with stroke,
they shown it in boxers.
You know that having one of those deals,
you're talking about a tenfold increased
risk of screwing up your brain.
You think that that's something that
they should screen for when they give
someone a license to fight.
I think that if I were a fighter,
I would want to know,
I'd want to know my risk and you're,
you're completely missing the psychology
of a fighter.
Fighters feel invulnerable.
Like the idea of a fighter is that
everybody else is going to get fucked
up,
but not me.
I'm going to be different.
I'm going to rise above.
I have a championships,
heart champion,
champion's heart,
champion's mindset.
I'm going to get through things that
other people can't.
You're not
going.
You're not going to.
If you have an April,
we for a little weird.
You're not.
Yeah.
You're,
you're bringing science into the world
of fighting.
I,
I would love for that to happen because
you're talking about possibly changing
the lives of like,
you know,
25 percent of fighters.
Fighters would still want to fight a
guarantee.
You a good majority of them.
I still want to fight and they would
just say,
well,
across our bridge when I come to it,
if I start feeling the difference,
but the real issue is once you start
feeling the issues,
you've only touched the tip of the
iceberg of the amount of damage that
you've actually
correct actually acquired.
Yes.
And once you start becoming symptomatic
in the sense where your memory,
short term memory becomes affected.
Like what we were talking about with
denny and our friend that is typical of,
you know,
a 80 year old human being that is
acquired 80 years of inflammatory
reactive oxygen species damage in the
brain,
you know,
then you start to see those symptoms.
Do you remember there was a story a few
years back of a football player.
Do you remember the football player?
The fell off the truck,
Jamie.
He jumped Henry,
Chris Henry.
That's it.
He was involved in some sort of a
dispute with his girlfriend or his wife,
forget which one.
And she took off with his truck and he
chased her and jumped on the back of the
truck and fell and fell off the truck
while she speeding down the road,
cracked his head open,
died.
They did a autopsy on him and found out
that he had the brain of a 70 something
year old Alzheimer's Alzheimer's
patient.
And he was in his twenties,
wasn't he?
Yeah.
Find out how old he was.
I'm,
uh,
I want to say he was 28 years old and he
had me.
This is a guy who had not expressed any
issues as far as like there's a bunch of
different athletes now that are coming
out and there has been an hbo real
sports piece that they just did this
past weekend that I watched about
football players,
violent expression that they're directly
relating to this traumatic brain injury
that they're suffering from football.
But this young man,
26,
26 and he had see if you can find the
article about him having.
Did it,
does it say he had about his brain
issue.
There was an article where they did the
autopsy on her research is find brain
trauma and Henry Twenty six years old.
Chronic and see.
I can't say that.
Encephalopathic encephalopathy.
Yes.
Well there's multiple things that you
brought up that is to say we could
discuss.
I think one is definitely the
accelerated brain aging that's happening
from the repeated traumatic events where
it's,
it's doing that
school football,
college football and the pros.
You're just into things
like a good chunk of your life and,
and,
and I did see one press release or some
article that was like 74 at a 76 or
something like nfl players or something
somewhat,
don't quote me on those statistics,
but something that was very,
very,
almost like 90 percent of them had a
Beta amyloid Beta plaques in their brain
and Tau tangles in the brain that were
characteristic of Alzheimer's disease.
Seventy six out of 79.
And this is post post death postmortem.
Yes,
yes,
exactly.
That's depression.
That's after birth.
She gave birth because they asked me if
I was mad.
That's how they got hit.
Um,
but yeah,
so,
uh,
the,
the other really interesting thing about
this traumatic brain injury is the
effects on behavior.
You mentioned you ran over there,
he ran chase chase car and jumped on the
truck and go off of it.
That's impulsive behavior.
I mean,
that's like not,
that's not a normal thing.
You don't just chase after a truck and
try to jump on it while it's moving
athletes and fighters and like really
that's a really common,
like the sort of impulsive behavior.
It's super common for fighters so.
Well,
there are definitely.
There's one aspect of the fighting
culture.
I mean,
you know,
there.
Yeah.
That's part of.
It's also what leads you to do that in
the first place is you have this ability
to do like a lot of them.
I mean,
I think before they ever got any brain
damage whatsoever.
They're impulsive people.
That's what led them to do fighting in
the first place.
I see.
You think that was part of the civil?
No,
I mean I'm guessing she certainly is.
I'm,
I'm guessing,
based on my own life,
so I don't know.
I think that,
you know,
people so impulsive behavior that's
related to impulsive aggression,
that can be self directed like suicide
or self harming.
It can also be like aggressive towards
others.
Impulsive behavior can be like not
longterm planning where you're just not.
You're not weighing out all the possible
you know,
events that can occur and what's more
likely to happen or not.
You know,
you're just impulsively do something.
There are polymorphisms that are related
to serotonin related genes that are
associated with that because Saratonin
plays a very important role in
regulating impulsivity,
so people that are already genetically
predisposed because they have a
polymorphism.
Again,
that gene variant that I was describing
earlier when I talked about a pui,
they have a gene variant in serotonin
synthesis gene or in the release
serotonin release or on the transporter
on the receptor.
You know,
they've shown that there are
associations with these and impulsivity.
You know,
Saratonin is one of the things that
happens.
I've talked about this before on the
podcast,
you know,
you can deplete.
People have Saratonin by taking away
their trip to fan and become impulsive
and they become impulsive in terms of
impulsive,
aggressive things.
You know,
when they do sorts of tests.
And that's partly because what's
happening is behavioral disinhibition.
Behavioral disinhibition is,
you know,
they're signaling that's happening.
That's going on from the orbital frontal
cortex part of the brain,
and it's happening.
It's signaling to other regions of the
brain,
like the Amygdala,
and I don't understand exactly how
serotonin does this or what his specific
role is.
I'd have to really dig into two more
neuroscience for that,
but I do know that it does play a very
important role in that when you take
away the Serotonin disinhibition occurs,
which means disinhibition means now
usually you're having inhibitory signals
happen that say,
okay,
you know,
you can't just go out and do something
crazy.
Like,
you know,
you can't do it and your brain knows
that and there's certain signals that's
happening.
When you take away Serotonin,
those signals go away.
And so now that inhibitory signal isn't
there.
Um,
this is something that I,
you know,
like I was doing some reading on some of
these nfl players that have gone crazy
and committed suicide.
I'm like,
junior sale I think is one who shot
himself in the heart,
you know,
because he specifically wanted his brain
to be examined,
examined,
and there was another football player,
I don't recall his name,
but he also committed suicide.
I think he shot himself in his heart as
well.
And then there was a pro wrestler,
um,
and I don't know his name,
but he liked it,
a murder suicide.
So these are all,
you know,
there's probably multiple things going
on.
The,
the,
the orbital frontal cortex.
So that plays a very important role in
inhibitory actions.
But when things start to get messed up
in that region of the brain,
including the Serotonin,
and I think,
like I mentioned,
the inflammation in the brain.
When you generate a two series
prostoglandins,
which happens when there's inflammation
in the brain,
you,
they've shown,
they've shown this in many different
studies in mice.
You inhibit the release of Serotonin.
So you take that,
you know,
in,
in of itself,
and you're talking about not having as
much of that Serotonin plus the damage
to the orbital frontal cortex.
And all these things are compounding.
You're talking about like just massive
changes in behavior that are occurring
and then on top of that you may have
someone that is,
like you said,
they,
they go into these sorts of sports for a
reason.
They're already impulsive,
so they,
you're talking to people that may
already be genetically predisposed,
they may already have some sort of
alteration in their serotonin function
and now they're depleting their
serotonin release on top of that and
they've got damage to their orbital
frontal cortex.
It's like these things are compounding
to cars,
just total impulsive behavior and you
know,
where they become aggressive and they do
crazy things that they normally
otherwise wouldn't do because they'd
have that impulsive.
I mean,
sorry,
they'd
have an inhibitory signal saying,
no,
don't do this.
You can't do this.
So,
you know,
I think it's very damaging in the
respects of changing the behavior of
these people to where they just become
even more impulsive and aggressive and
they're already,
you know,
in this,
in the case of fighters,
they're already fighting.
It's already a culture thing,
you know.
So,
uh,
it's,
it's something very interesting with the
serotonin system also in the interaction
between inflammation and Serotonin and
they've even shown the opposite,
like when you take people and you give
them an acute dose of like an Ssri and
you flood the brain with Serotonin just
acutely just for like,
you know,
a couple of hours people become more
adverse to harming others.
Like when you do give them a,
you know,
like uh,
one of those questionnaire things,
they become more adverse to harming
others even at the expense of saving
other more people.
Uh,
so serotonin is somehow regulating these
types of,
I don't know,
you know,
and there's neuroscientists and
philosophers and all this that are doing
this research and trying to understand
it doesn't make sense so that happy
people would be more kind and less
likely to harm others.
And I've found personally that people
that are most oppressed or the most
likely to fucking slash and burn those,
those are the people that want to take
everybody down with them.
It's usually the people that are really
depressed that are looking to make other
people feel bad.
Yeah.
I think happiness is a is a component,
but I also think the impulsivity is
another component that's important.
It seems that Serotonin,
if that really is what's going on,
that giving someone a large dose of
Serotonin would actually make them less
likely to want to harm other people.
That's a pretty significant thing.
Yes.
That,
that study was published,
I don't know,
like 2010 or so I think and they're,
they're looking into,
they're doing a lot of follow up studies
on that.
Like you know,
there's a difference between giving
someone an acute dose of Serotonin,
flooding their brain and doing it
constantly,
you know,
because when you're constantly doing it,
then there's feedback loops and you
start to decrease the amount of
serotonin receptors and the Bra.
Yeah.
So that's so,
you know,
but anyway,
it's just the fact,
what they're trying to understand is
what is serotonin doing?
Like why is it that by giving someone a
huge dose of it,
they become more adverse to harming
others and I don't know the answer.
You know,
it just seems like there'd be happier.
Right?
I mean,
if you,
if your Serotonin,
part of its function is to promote
happiness,
right?
It's just one of the reasons why Ssri or
termed antidepressants because people
who are on depressants,
they take these regulators are serotonin
and gives them a big uptake in it and
then Ooh,
they feel better.
I don't know if it's as clear cut,
but it does,
you know,
I'm simplifying.
It does affect mood.
Yeah,
it does.
You do feel better.
Um,
it,
they've shown also the Serotonin,
a Ssri
effect,
pain like you pain,
so you actually feel less pain.
So it's not just a matter of feeling
happier.
It's also a matter of not feeling as
much pain.
And there's similar pathways between
physical pain and social pain.
I have a friend who had depression
issues and before being on Ssri,
he was like really angry.
Like fuck everybody,
fuck this guy.
And like he would say horrible things
about people.
Once he got on the antidepressants,
all that went away now couldn't care
less what other people do.
Couldn't care less.
Like who cares?
Like someone's doing something bad or
someone saying something bad or
whatever.
He's like,
I don't care,
just doesn't bother me.
I'm not,
I don't want to harm that person.
You know?
It's a complete shift in his mindset.
Yeah Sir.
Serotonin does affect that,
uh,
that aggressiveness,
you know,
like I,
it's,
it's definitely playing a role.
Well,
it's more of a lash out sort of a thing,
but I think there's,
one of the issues with depression is
that people that are depressed and
people that do have depression issues,
they kind of want to bring other people
into their world almost like they feel
like that people,
other people being happy is some somehow
taking something away from them,
you know?
Yeah,
yeah,
I do.
I think,
you know,
they want to surround that.
They want other people to be miserable,
miserable with them.
I think in this sense also where it's
like,
because it's justification,
it's like I'm here,
then it must be okay and you know,
if everyone here is also here with me,
then yeah,
then I'm not,
I'm,
I'm not abnormal.
There's not something wrong.
I've always wondered how much of that is
what's going on psychologically,
how much of that is what's in their life
and how much of the psychology and how
much of what's going on in their life.
Like what kind of feedback they're
getting on daily day to day basis in
their life is actually regulating their
human neurochemistry.
Yeah,
yeah.
No.
There is a very complex interaction
going on between the environment and the
neurochemistry and this has been
demonstrated,
you know,
in a lot of different animal studies
where it's like,
so you can actually alter someone
serotonin system by having an early
life,
you know,
stressful event happen.
So you know,
like in the case of mice and early life,
stressful event is when the pups,
when you're born you're a pup and you're
not nurtured as a pop.
So when you're nurtured,
you know the parent mice will lick the
pops and when that,
when they get licked you will.
They release Serotonin in their brain
when they're really,
really young.
And when happens,
when they released her tone into the
Brown,
they're really young.
It's all sorts of feedback,
epigenetic feedback loops.
So epigenetics is changing the
expression of their genes without
actually altering the DNA nucleotide
sequence,
like a polymorphism is different
sequence of DNA,
but epigenetically they'll change the
receptors in their brain that respond,
that respond to like Glucocorticoids,
like stress hormones,
and they incur.
So when they have serotonin there,
they increased the amount of receptors,
which means when they have more
receptors to glucocorticoids,
your body doesn't make us shoot as much
cortisol and much much for the
glucocorticoids out because it has a lot
of receptors.
There's a feedback so they're calmer,
they're happier,
they're not as anxious,
but if you take that away and those
pumps don't get licked,
they don't make Serotonin in early
development and those glucocorticoid
receptors,
you don't have as many.
And so the body is constantly.
It's like in a stress state and these,
these mice grew up very,
very anxious,
fearful.
I'm just,
you know,
their,
their brains develop differently.
Is that the same with children that grow
up in orphanages where they don't get
cuddled and.
Yeah,
I mean that's what I would be.
That's what I think.
It seems likely that you take that in
combination.
So you've got someone who's already
genetically predisposed.
I like,
you know,
the serotonin system because it,
we're talking a lot about that.
They're already,
they already have a polymorph and these
things,
polymorphisms are common.
You've got people with polymorphisms in
Serotonin transporters,
serotonin synthesis genes or their
receptors,
and so they're already kind of
vulnerable.
They're already,
you know,
they're not making as much serotonin or
they're not responding it like,
like normal,
so they're already genetically
vulnerable to that.
And then you couple that with an early
stressful event and then it just screws
things up even more.
Uh,
and also diet is coupled to it.
I'm going to have talked about vitamin
deregulating serotonin synthesis.
EPA regulates the release of it.
They've shown that.
I mentioned the two series.
Prostoglandins inhibits the release when
you,
when you put EPA,
and it mitigates that.
So having an anti inflammatory Omega
three,
you know,
is very important for people that are
genetically predisposed to have their
serotonin system screwed up.
You take that person anything about
someone who's already on the fringe
who's already waiting to be tipped over
into mental illness or behavioral types
of behaviors that are non productive and
you and you take their nutrition,
they don't,
they have poor nutrition there,
inflammation going on,
so all the energy is going sucked into
the wrong place and not up here where it
needs to be.
And then you add stressful environment.
I mean you're talking about dynamite for
mental illness and not just stressful
environment,
but negative feedback or negative
environment.
Yeah.
Poor a poor relationships,
poor friendships,
real hardcore negativity.
Yeah.
They've even shown actually in terms of
the relationships,
this,
this whole behavioral epigenetics,
so to speak,
is kind of what it's called.
And it's very interesting because it's
talking,
it's like the relationship between
what's happening in your environment and
how that's changing,
you know,
things that the neurochemistry in your
brain either at the level of
neurotransmitters or receptors or
whatever they've shown that another.
So another thing that happens when
you're a cuddled,
you're young and they do a lot of these
studies in mice,
um,
obviously,
but you release like,
like for example,
when your mother licks you,
you also,
there's also oxytocin being released and
oxytocin sort of that bonding hormone
that's made where the mother bonds with
the trial.
But also it's,
it's,
it's pair,
you know,
mate bond bonding as well.
And so when you take that away,
uh,
when,
when you know,
like,
like if you're not coddled or you don't
get that attention early,
like that early attention from the
mother in early life,
then what happens is that the,
the offspring grow up and they make less
oxytocin.
Like some epigenetic changes are
happening where now they're not making
as much.
So now they grow up and they don't bond
to their children and it perpetuates and
they don't bond to their relations.
So they have poor relationships.
Similar thing happens with Vasopressin,
which is,
it's very a vasopressor and regulates a
lot of things.
It's also an antidiuretic,
but interestingly it's also made in the
brain and it's important for male,
like males respond to it in the context
of meeting.
So like for example,
they,
they've shown in like prairie voles,
which are rodents that are monogamous.
They,
um,
they have higher level,
they have a higher level of receptors
for that.
Vas are present in their brain compared
to other species that are not
monogamous.
And when they take away,
when researchers take away the ability
to take away those,
they basically antagonize the receptors
so it can't bind Vasopressin,
those prairie voles which are monogamous
and they,
they,
they mate for life.
All of a sudden that goes away.
Let's take it.
They become freaks.
Like,
yeah,
polygamist and stuff.
And they've shown this in like nonhuman
primates to where I think it was like
Alma Alma keys.
They're monogamous and you look at it
and you compare them to,
um,
reduce monkeys that are non non
monogamous.
There the difference is also at the
receptors for bas or precedent that
monogamist ones have a high density of
them in their brain.
And then another study came out looking
at humans.
I'm in a Swedish cohort.
They looked at males that were in
monogamous relationships that were
married,
had successful relationships versus ones
that were divorced.
I'm also ones that were just single and
they found that there was an association
again with these vasopressin receptors
in the brain where the men that were,
uh,
had failed marriages,
for example,
or we're not likely to even get married.
They had less of these vasopressin
receptors.
Um,
so it's really interesting that there's
these social hormones that we're making
that are really changed epigenetically.
So these are also,
like,
for example,
in the prairie voles,
they release more of this Vasopressin
when they're meeting,
so like the act of mating with their
monogamous,
with their partner that they partner
with for life.
Uh,
there's something that goes on with that
meeting event,
that bonding event that makes,
makes them more monogamous.
Exactly.
And it's happening.
I don't remember if,
I think it was happening at the level of
the receptor.
Yes.
They were making more of the receptors.
The meeting event caused them to
strengthen that bond
more.
No,
it'd be fascinating.
Is if they could figure out some way to
experiment with Benobos who are patently
polygamous.
Bonobos are freaks.
They just have sex with everybody there.
The only.
The only frictions.
Yeah,
they do.
they're.
They're homosexual.
The only restrictions are the mother
won't meet with the suns.
That's it.
Everything else is a free party and it
would be fascinating if they could
figure out a way to introduce that.
Could you.
Can you introduce it?
Yes.
You can make a transgenic and until
recently,
transgenic by Informa Diet or a
transgenic in the context of,
of biology on means that we take a piece
of DNA,
like a gene that does something and we
put it into any species of rodents and
we make it like we can give rodents,
human genes and study their effects are
we can give Rodin's genes that we give
them more of them and see what happens
so we can take away.
Got started.
Probably so fucking disaster.
So we do it in rodents.
That's the chimps.
So now with this,
we.
There was some limiting ability with the
cloning techniques and how we do it,
but now we can do it more readily,
so I think those studies are going to be
done yet.
But you're right.
There's always the variability that you.
The chaotic factor.
It's like,
well,
what if wake up,
what if they like become really smart?
Start over,
right?
Sure.
But the Zune,
the chimps have fucking welding masks on
making sorts.
That would be Kinda cool.
Yeah,
in a way.
Terrifying.
Yes.
I mean a lot meaner than people,
but nobody aren't.
Yeah.
Which is really fascinating because
they're like the least violent of all
the primates or one of the least
violent.
They almost never harm each other
because they're having so much sex
wonder,
but.
But chimps have a lot of sex too.
They don't have as much sex as Banabos
for sure,
but Benobos have so much sex.
They don't use them in captivity.
You never see Benobos at the zoo and the
reason being is that they're just so
hypersexual.
They people would find a defensive
because western culture so ridiculously
suppressed.
If we had benobos in the zoo,
we couldn't say,
well,
this is the thing.
What you're looking at here is a normal
natural expression of Banabos.
They like to have sex with each other.
They solve disputes with sex,
they use sex for bargaining and we know
that chimps use bargaining for sex.
And I had an old bit about it was
because one of the first things that
they ever discovered about chimpanzees
when they started experimenting with
money,
they started giving chimps coins and
they could give those coins and get
fruit with it.
So the first thing they did was give the
coins the females and have sex with
them.
We're really the thing,
the,
once they realized the coins represented
food,
they would give the coins,
the females and the females would just
have fucking stacks of coins to the
ceiling and all these males would be
having sex with them.
That associative learning where then
they immediately been able to realize,
okay,
this prostitution is genetic.
Um,
yeah.
Interestingly,
back onto the.
I mean,
I guess it's not really prostitution,
but back on the whole life style and how
that changes your behavior.
They've also shown that in mice when
they female minds,
so when female mice,
when they're not cuddled.
So there's a lot of this in behavioral
epigenetics stuff that they're doing.
They do a lot of studies on,
okay,
what happens in early development?
You know,
what happens to the brain,
like if you're not,
you know,
if you don't get attention,
you don't get the cuddling and licking.
How do you grow up like what's going on?
And with the females,
what happens too is they,
uh,
when they don't get cuddled and licked
and all that,
they grow up with more estrogen
receptors in their brain and they become
more sexually receptive.
So estrogen is make,
makes females more sexually receptive.
And so what ends up happening is usually
when you put a male mouse into a cage
with a female mouse,
she may or may not meet with them.
And if you put,
if you put one male mouse into the cage
with her,
this is a normal,
like a mass attach,
cuddling coddling.
And all that,
uh,
you put the second male mouse in,
let's say she made it with the first
one,
you put the second one in and it's,
she's not going to just meet with this
guy.
It's like she already made it,
you know,
she's not,
she's not promiscuous where she just
having sex and after sex after,
you know.
But what happens with those female
mindset grow up without that cuddling,
they have increased,
epigenetically increased expression of
estrogen receptors in their brain to
become more promiscuous.
And you put it,
you put a male mouse in again and it
will make.
And you put another one in and it made.
So it's changing the sexual behavior.
Now,
you know,
whether I'm sorry,
but isn't there a correlation with human
beings?
Because human beings are come from
troubled childhoods with the lack of
love tend to be more promiscuous.
Yeah,
I mean,
I agree.
You know,
obviously I can't make that statement,
but yeah,
you did.
The more we learn about,
you know,
how these early life events are
affecting behavior of our own brain and
also of our offspring.
Um,
you know,
like the more we can start to apply this
to humans,
I think it makes sense,
you know,
I think there's definitely a correlation
between um,
growing up in poverty,
growing up,
you know,
with,
without having that family there,
that love nurturing supportive system,
whether it's a single parent,
it's not,
it's not necessarily the case.
I'm not saying like I grew up in a
single parent home and you know,
I'm not out there frequently.
Yeah,
freaking getting free gun kind of.
I get my science free gone,
but I'm a little different.
So yeah,
I,
I'm just saying I don't want to like say
that everyone,
there's definitely no exceptions,
but yeah,
but I do think that our increased
understanding at the biochemical level
of how the environment changes the
brain,
you know,
whether we're talking about behavior,
cognitive function,
you know,
in general is very interesting and I
think that it should be extrapolated and
sort of apply to humans and in hopes
that we can start to make society
better.
You know,
it's just so fascinating to me that a
human being is essentially the product
of an equation.
The equation of all these different
hormones,
all these different neurotransmitters,
all these different epigenetic factors,
all these different life experience
factors,
all these different things.
It's just that,
that's what producers are.
Rhonda,
Patrick.
I mean,
it's,
it's amazing.
It's so,
it's so complex.
I agree with you.
I think,
you know,
there's a lot of years the things that
we cannot control,
you know,
and the things that we cannot control,
our,
you know,
our polymorphisms that we're born with,
like me being born with apo e four,
I can't control that or it's hard to
control,
you know,
being raised in a family where let's
say,
you know,
you're from a single parent family and
your mom's working hard.
She doesn't have time to,
you know,
you don't,
you don't get as much nurturing.
Dad's gone,
you know,
that sort of thing.
You can't choose that.
I mean,
you,
you're very young.
You know,
when you're a young infant and young
toddler,
I mean these,
your brain is very susceptible to all
these environmental interactions that's
epigenetically changing the way your
brain is working.
Um,
but things that you can change are,
you know,
as you know,
diet diets are really important.
One that you can change,
you know,
the whole ballgame.
Basically.
It's,
you know,
you're talking about,
I really think there is a complex
interaction between genetics,
epigenetics,
diet,
and you know,
I'm not the only one that thinks that,
I mean there is,
there's people researching all these
different complex interactions.
But I think what I like to focus on is
the part that we can control and the
part that we can control right now.
And that is,
you know,
our lifestyle.
We,
what we,
what we as an adult at least,
you know,
obviously when you're really young
you're sort of beholden to your parents
feeding you and also,
you know,
that's the sort of unfortunate.
But at a certain point,
you know,
it's like when you're able to realize
what's going on,
I think that trying to control what you
can is really important.
So getting a good diet,
you know,
things like getting enough Omega threes,
EPA and your brain is literally an
antiinflammatory.
It's extremely,
extremely important.
Like,
you know,
this study where they're injecting
people with cytokines that are causing
inflammation,
that gives them depression and yet if
they take epa with it,
they don't get depressed.
Yeah,
that's pretty.
That's a massively
significant.
It would be a huge issue with children
as well.
I,
I definitely think it's a huge issue
with children.
They have these,
um,
these,
the,
there's various um,
uh,
fish oil,
gummy bears and these different little
candies that you can give the children.
They don't really taste like candy,
the context quite a bit shittier than
candy,
but they're sweet enough so they feel
like a treat the kids.
I think that it's extremely important,
especially early on to get to get that
EPA.
I know I've talked about in the past,
Dha has always talked about because it's
high,
there's a high level of it and the brain
and I even talked about it in the
context of Krill oil.
I did some research after our last
conversation.
We had a conversation about that.
That's one of the things that keeps
coming up on my message board guys
wanting to.
Folks wanted to question you about that.
Like what is the difference trend Krill
oil and fish oil and what,
what are the benefits of curoil and also
how do you know whether crow was rancid
because that appears to be an issue with
Krill oil.
Really friendly with crude oil.
Interesting.
Okay.
Well I'll tell you what I know and I'll
definitely tell you what I don't care.
So the thing you know,
the reason Dha and EPA are very
important is because they're,
they're both an important part of the
brain in terms of Dha.
It's very important because it's part of
the cell membrane.
I'm like new neurons are astrocytes and
other cells in your body,
but particularly it's concentrated in
the gray matter of the brain.
So it's very important.
The difference between fish oil and
Krill oil.
And you know this,
this is something that I made a video on
recently is is that sufficient oil is
usually a molecularly distilled because
they use it to fish,
have higher on the food chain and
they've got concentration of more bad
things like mercury and they're fat and
so they molecularly distill it to get
rid of that junk because we don't want
to take a bunch of,
you know,
mercury.
And also they,
they distill it because they want to
concentrate the fish,
the EPA and Dha to make it more
concentrated.
So what they do is they take the fit,
the EPA and Dha and they put this like
ethanol backbone.
They usually,
it has a glycerol backbone on it,
which makes it a triglyceride and they
take that off and they do this ethanol
backbone.
It's part of the molecular distillation
process.
How they distill it,
get the impurities away.
But then most companies leave it like
that.
They don't put it back in a triglyceride
form.
So they have this ethanol backbone,
which is not recognized very well by
pancreatic lipase,
is in our small intestine.
So it doesn't get absorbed very well
because that's,
you know,
an ethanol backbone.
It's not common,
it's,
it does get absorbed,
but you just have to take more of it.
Fish oil can be reestablished into a
triglyceride form where they put
glycerol back on and that is much better
because know the triglyceride is what
these,
these
pancreatic lipase is,
are used to seeing so they can absorb
it.
Your small intestines can absorb it
better.
So the bioavailability is better
essentially.
So,
but the problem is most fish oil
supplements don't do that.
There's a,
there's a couple of exceptions.
I know Nordic naturals is one.
Um,
I like them.
So that's the fish oil.
Krill oil is mostly in a phospholipid
form.
And so that.
The thing about the phospholipid form,
much like when we were talking about
with liposomes is so the thing with
phospholipid form is that the,
the Dha and EPA and Krill oil can be
easily absorbed by the small intestine
for one,
it can be absorbed and it's intact form
without having to undergo all this
enzymatic cleavage stuff so it can just
be absorbed intact and get transported
to the cholesterol at clough microns
like hdl ldl that can be transported
there in full tax form.
Um,
but so that's,
you know,
better bioavailability,
so to speak.
And there's been a couple of studies
showing that there's a 40 percent
increase in bioavailability and from
getting EPA and Dha in phospholipid form
from Krill oil versus getting into a
triglyceride form from fish oil.
So that's Kinda cool.
Um,
the,
the thing that's really cool about Krill
oil is that this phospholipid form,
um,
is,
is great because Dha,
to get Dha into the brain,
we actually have a transporter,
which means you can get the of the brain
by just having it as a fatty acid,
free fatty acid and it can be carried
into the brain.
But there's also a specific transporter
that has dha in a certain kind of fossil
liquid form called phosphatidylcholine.
Phosphatidylcholine is a phospholipid
and it isn't Krill oil and it's pretty
awesome because the that Dha
lysophosphatidylcholine can transport
transport's Dha into the brand.
It's actually an important way that Dha
gets into the brain.
In fact,
when they knock out that transporter in
mice,
mice had 60,
60 percent less Dha in their brain.
So it's obviously an important pathway.
The brain likes it in that form.
So I think for for for that reason in
and of itself,
Krill oil was cool for the Dha because
it's in that lie.
So phosphatidylcholine form.
However,
that's not the whole story.
I think that a fish oil,
because fish oil concentrates the EPA
and Dha to insane levels.
I mean even though Krill oil is more
bioavailable,
you know,
it doesn't have high levels of EPA or
Dha to speak,
but your brain doesn't need that much.
Dha,
your brain conserves Dha very,
very well.
The half life of Dha is like anywhere
between like six months to a year.
It's like very,
very long.
Your brain is conserving it and the
brain doesn't take up a lot,
so on a daily basis,
I think it's something like four
milligrams a day,
so your brain isn't taking up a whole
lot of Dha,
but when it does take it up,
it likes it in that Krill oil form,
that phospholipid form,
EPA,
EPA is the thing that your brain needs a
lot of constant supply and EPA is so
important for so many different reasons.
We're talking about,
you know,
that whole neuro inflammatory pathway
that we started out talking about with,
you know,
traumatic brain injury with just normal
brain aging with inflammation in
general.
Anything going on in the body will be
any sort of gut issues.
All that stuff that's affecting the
brain.
And so,
you know,
having EPA in the brain is so important.
It's so important.
And so I like to get a concentrated
amount of EPA from fish oil.
I get mine and triglyceride form.
So I use Nordic naturals because.
So I actually take both.
I take Krill oil and I take fish oil
because I think the Krill oil is awesome
for the Dha in that phosphatidylcholine
form and I think that the fish oil,
because I can get like I try to get to
grams,
they've shown like multiple,
multiple studies have shown whether I'm
looking at cognitive function,
whether I'm looking at depression,
whether I'm looking at impulsive
behavior or other types of brain
functions and behaviors to Graham seems
to be a consensus in terms of benefits.
So that's 2000 milligrams.
Yes.
And so I get that from my mind,
Nordic naturals EPA that I take.
And then I get my Dha from Krill oil.
Um,
the other thing about the Krill oil is
it has asked,
is dampen,
which is a crock annoyed that is,
I'm also accumulates in the rods and
cones in the eye and also in the brain.
And the reason it does that is because
it has a unique structure that is able
to sequester singlet oxygen which is
produced by UV light.
The Sun singlet oxygen is the thing that
damages our eyes with age.
It's very real.
It's one of those reactive oxygen
species that I talk about and it damages
the rods and the cones of the eye and
it's a,
it's a cause of,
you know,
age related blindness,
whether we're talking about macular
degeneration,
degeneration or other sorts of,
you know,
uh,
I dibella attaining diseases,
so I'm asked is anthon,
Lutein,
zeaxanthin.
These are carotinoids that are really,
really good.
And they accumulate in the eye because
they're like basically every time we're
out in the sun and that blue light hits
which caused,
which has the elect,
the singlet oxygen in it,
it captures it and it stops it from
damaging brain and also eyes.
So acids,
anthony is really cool.
It's also been shown in clinical studies
to,
you know,
improve hdl to have know lower oxidation
locks at lower oxidative stress.
All these good sorts of goodies that
come along with it,
which I also think are really cool.
I like and um,
in terms of rancidity,
I personally,
the reason,
another reason why I take Nordic
naturals is because of the isolate their
fish oil under nitrogen conditions,
meaning there's no oxygen oxygen
present.
So in order for these Omega threes to
get damaged,
they need to be oxidized.
So part of the whole distillation
process,
the pilling,
all that stuff,
you're,
you're exposing it to oxidative damage.
And so the fact that Nordic naturals
does all that in a nitrogen
conditioning,
there's no oxygen present.
So it's kind of awesome.
Now,
the Krill oil rancidity,
uh,
I wasn't aware of how
rents rancid it gets just because I'm
sort of new to the Krill oil field.
I just did a lot of reading on this Dha
phosphatidylcholine form.
It's probably a similar situation,
right?
Probably is.
Xanthan is a very good at it.
It's also good at preventing lipid
peroxidation.
So it's,
you know,
it's doing some good students.
It's an antioxidant,
it's preventing a lot of that rancidity
just a matter of maybe how much as
Stanton's in there.
That's possible.
I've seen various doses,
so maybe more acid antin would help
prevent the rancidity uh,
in that,
in that regard.
But,
um,
that would be one thing that I would
look for if you're getting.
The Cro will try to get a higher level
thinking of macular degeneration and our
issues.
What,
what specifically is a good thing to
take for vision?
I've heard core sutton.
Is that what it's Quercitin yeah,
of course.
It's supposed to promote healthy vision.
Even better than that is Lutein and
Zeaxanthin leading the team as well.
This sort of thing.
There's this pure has a macular health
packet or some supplements they saved
that has both that loot.
That's,
you say Ludy and Lutein,
looting,
Z Z is absent 10.
Yeah,
I'm not,
I'm not.
I mean that's course attendance.
Just got generalized mechanisms where it
activates NRF two,
which is a transcription factor that
activates glutathione.
So it's,
you know,
it's one of those broad spectrum kind of
like the curcumin where it turns on a
lot of good good genes in the body.
Um,
but really if we're talking about the
idea,
ha,
Lutein and Zeaxanthin,
uh,
the,
they're really the main ones and moving
into Xanthan are present in like green
plants is really high in it.
Um,
Zucchini,
you know,
these things that it has all those
things is a pure one.
The one that I'd say has,
um,
has looting,
it has a zs,
a in the course attend as well as well
as a and Siedel l sighting and inositol
assisting cystine.
Is that what it says?
Yes.
Yeah.
So actually that's another inositol
sustain is another way that you can
activate nrf two and also glutathione
and it's also a potent antioxidant.
Um,
you know,
I don't know it.
It's not like a general thing that's
specific to the eye.
It's more of a,
sorry,
not a specific thing to the eye.
It's more of a general thing.
It can induce glutathione synthesis,
so it's,
you know,
it's one of those things that are good
for multiple cells,
but especially when I'm,
if we're just talking about the eye
lutein and Zeaxanthin,
like if you look in other tissues,
the only place you find it is in the eye
and the rods and the cones in the eye
and in the brain.
That's it.
That's where it accumulates.
Whereas n-acetyl NSU assisting gets in
like multiple cells.
It's just doing a general antioxidant
thing.
So having the Lutein and Suzanne and
that's part of the.
I think this,
I make a smoothie every morning,
which has a lot of Kale in it and other
Greens,
but it's got a high concentration of
Lutein and Zeaxanthin.
Also,
my multivitamin has it as well.
I think I'm confusing corset in with
something else because I think it was
looting there was thinking about,
because I don't even think this pure
mentor,
probably what you were thinking about
looting his course it into something
else.
Right.
It's a polyphenol.
Yeah,
it's good.
I mean it does a lot of good things.
You know that a lot of the mechanisms by
which these polyphenols work is through
that,
it's slightly toxic.
It activates all these different genes
in our tissues that are detoxifying
enzymes like with Ioan and other
reactive oxygen species,
scavengers and things like that.
So inositol sustaining has been shown to
activate all the glutathione genes so
those,
you know,
it's,
it's a,
it's one of those mechanisms where it's
like,
it,
like I mentioned before,
the hormetic response.
It's kind of like that where it does
something like that generalizing
response.
You talked earlier about something that
I always thought it was bullshit that,
um,
the,
the herbal shit that everybody always
prescribed when people are sick at
conation.
I always thought it was nonsense.
I don't,
I don't know if it is or not.
I just,
I mentioned it because I know that it's
in people's minds.
It's an herbal thing that people going
to take a couple of jobs of recognition
when you're on it and never did
anything.
I never felt any increased,
uh,
you know,
healing or recovery from colds.
I honestly have no idea if it's,
if it's real or not because I haven't
read about it enough.
I mean,
I think the best thing to do,
like we were talking about,
you know,
is making sure you don't have a lot of
inflammation going on.
Making sure you're healthy.
Like that's gonna be the way to have the
best immune response you can possibly
have when you are exposed to something
pathogenic.
It's fascinating the way human beings
work because we always go to try to fix
it once it's broken and don't try to
prevent it from being fixed.
Like there's a,
there's a lot of money.
Well,
there's a lot of money in health
supplements,
but there's a lot of money and like
homeopathic remedies once you're already
sick.
Like I remember,
I don't remember who gave it to me,
but I remember there's this stuff,
it's like these little,
like little sugar capsules there.
You pop the top and put in your mouth.
I'm like,
I'm eating sugar.
Was it?
Homeopathy is nonsense.
No,
no,
no.
This is amazing.
Homeopathic remedy for Kohl's.
I go,
this is fucking sugar sugar effect.
Is that what it is?
Yeah.
Yeah,
I think that.
Is that stuff called,
you know what I'm talking about?
No,
you pop the top of it.
It's like sugar crystals now.
I've never,
I have no idea what you're talking
about.
But I do know that homeopathic stuff is,
there's just no way that can be
effective.
The way that diluted to the point where
there's like one molecule of the
compound in.
It's just crazy.
Um,
I did,
I was given,
given that once,
and I took one I didn't know was
homeopathic,
but I thought it was like Arnica or
something.
And I took it,
but it was like little tiny little cap,
like sugar things inside of it.
And I could tell just by the way I shook
the capsule,
I didn't,
I didn't pop it open.
Maybe I was supposed to,
I don't know,
I just took the capsule.
But anyways,
that that's when his Arnica Arnica is,
um,
it's,
it's anti inflammatory or anti microbial
mean.
It's used for like mouthwash kind of
thing.
It's,
it's potent at inhibiting.
I'm aerobic bacteria.
Bacteria that are aerobic.
So,
so that's,
you know,
I haven't done a ton of research on the,
but it's the one thing that it does do
golden rule is another one that's always
partnered with Achalasia gold.
Golden Seal.
Golden.
That's right.
No,
you're right.
You're,
you're bringing back memories from like,
I don't know because I just haven't
looked into those.
I haven't been.
I know the things that are good are the
polyphenols course to 10 in Kerman
Turmeric in general because of the
tomorrow.
And I'm the inositol assisting in Alpha
lipoic acid is another way to increase
glutathione.
That's also impart important for
mitochondrial function.
So,
you know,
there are,
there are good things and who knows some
of these.
Yeah,
Alpha lipoic acid is interesting
because,
um,
my actually my mentor,
he is one of the pioneers that showed
when you give alpha lipoic acid to old
rats showed this like,
I don't know,
15 years ago,
I guess it made them young again,
like their brain,
like made their brains young.
So when you gave them to old rats,
it was reversing aging.
How do they administer?
It was an intravenous.
Oh,
you know,
I don't remember.
I don't remember if it was intravenous
or not.
I can easily check that,
check that out.
But Alpha lipoic acid does get absorbed.
It actually gets absorbed better when
it's not taken with protein,
interestingly enough,
because it binds.
Usually it's something we make
ourselves,
like plants make it,
it's in,
it's in food that we eat and it's also,
you know,
we have,
we make it in our body,
um,
but it,
when it's complex to protein for some
reason.
And I don't,
it's been so long.
It's been quite a few years since I read
about this mechanism.
But something about it,
um,
does it doesn't get absorbed because
it's like getting cleaved away or
something with the protein.
So actually taking Alpha lipoic acid
supplement should be taken on an empty
stomach.
I'm sorry,
go ahead.
Yeah.
No.
Which is kind of different than other
foods where you take them with morphine
or how many people like listen to all
this information and there's a lot of
people listening this podcast right now,
like fuck,
there's too much to really take into
consideration.
There's too much.
Like,
okay,
I need some of that,
but I don't want protein.
Okay.
What do I take it?
Light bulbs,
Somo,
gludethyon.
Is that legit or do I need a lot of fun?
Okay.
So I'll take turmeric and then I'll get
my,
the same thing
that I would get from people on the
subway right now,
writing on their hands,
trying to put all the shit in their
head.
How much stuff should you take a day?
And how much of this can you get from
your food?
Can you get this free food?
Yeah,
absolutely.
Like there's apple podcasts and your
food when you're cooking.
What kind of foods?
I think,
you know,
I think that it's,
Joe,
it's been so long I can't,
I can't recall which ones have the,
most of it.
It's in a lot of foods,
but in terms of concentration wise,
I forgot.
But the thing is,
is that,
you know,
like I'll take alpha lipoic acid.
It's not part of my staple,
you know,
my,
what I really,
really focused on is on micronutrients
that are part of all these biochemical
pathways that are going on in all of
ourselves,
including our brain.
Those things I want to make sure I'm
getting.
That's key.
So getting the Omega threes,
getting my EPA,
Dha,
getting vitamin D,
magnesium,
getting all my minerals,
calcium,
magnesium,
getting that right,
making sure I get all that stuff.
Vitamin C,
like all I need all those micronutrients
and I want to make sure I get that.
That's most important.
Um,
the other stuff,
you know,
like the taking the current curcumin or
turmeric and I'm glad with my own things
like that,
you know,
those are more,
I think other measures that you can,
I think first and foremost,
healthy diet,
you know,
making sure you're eliminating the
inflammation at the source of it,
which is,
you know,
making sure you're not causing too much
inflammation by eating,
eating sugar and refined crap.
Just eat.
You want to make sure you're eating a
lot of micronutrients,
eating your meats that are not all crazy
a processed.
Yeah.
And nitrites and nitrates night.
Well,
nitrates aren't used for um,
you know,
they're in,
they're an all plant later,
like everywhere in nature.
Um,
nitrites are used to cure me and like
lunch meats and bake a lot of bacon,
I think has it.
Um,
the difference is that I try,
it's can form a nature,
a nitrosamines which are potent
carcinogens.
So they basically what they do is they
bind to your DNA and they formed this
bolt,
bulky adduct on your DNA.
And what happens is when your cell tries
to replicate,
so that's DNA damage,
a bulky addicts and I trusted means they
like interact with DNA and then when the
cell replicates,
like the,
the,
the replication machinery,
you can't recognize that DNA sequence
because there's a big thing sitting
there and so it just puts anything there
and it's actually associated with a
specific type of mutation.
I think it's a Gett one.
It's been a while.
But,
um,
that causes,
that's associated with cancer,
which is why it's labeled as a
carcinogen.
Um,
so nitrites can form that.
mostly because they're in,
when they're in an accurate,
accurate solution,
they conform nitrous acid which then can
react with amiens which are everywhere.
And proteins like amino acids,
like ambience.
So that reacted to,
that,
informed them,
conform on,
I trusted me.
So that's not a good thing.
And nitrates,
you can form.
Nitrates can form nitrites,
like in the saliva,
we have bacteria in our saliva that can
do that.
And I've seen studies everywhere and
anywhere ranging from like five,
five to 20 percent or something like
that where it can form.
Nitrates are starting nitrites and
nitrates conform,
so eating lots of plants to inform which
get into your system,
but a significant amount can be toxic.
Well,
um,
so while there is,
I don't remember what the toxicity,
I think that there is something that can
happen,
but so there's a,
there's a nitrates conform nitric oxide,
which is a vasodilator.
It's,
you know,
it's kind of a good thing and actually
they use,
sometimes they use that to help people
with hypertension.
Um,
and I tried to,
can also form that,
but it depends on whether or not there's
enough antioxidant around like vitamin C
or other antioxidants because nitrites,
because they'd be formed this nitrous
acid acid in acquia solution,
they can immediately then go into
nitrogen means,
but if you have this reducing agent
around,
then you can shift them nitrites to form
night nitris nitric oxide.
Uh,
but so plants,
right,
which is good,
but so plants have a lot of vitamin C
when you're eating the nitrates in the
plants,
you're getting vitamin C,
you're getting all these antioxidants,
vitamin CS and Kale,
celery,
all that stuff.
It's there.
So you don't,
they've done studies where they've
looked at the amount of nitrogen means
formed from either nitrites or nitrates
and like so for meat like meat,
nitrates that are cured meat and they've
shown that nitrates don't form those as
readily because it's warming the nitric
oxide instead,
especially because there's a lot of
vitamin C around which inhibits the
formation of the nitrogen mean if you,
if you take the nitrites and the cured
me,
then you're not getting a lot of
antioxidants unless you're eating them
also with it.
Uh,
but in the case where you're cooking the
nitrites cooking is dangerous because
can be dangerous because when you cook
water,
you know,
water is,
have you get water and the nitrites in,
in accurate solution and water form
nitrogen form nitric acid which then
react with the degradation products of
amino acids from like Bacon for example,
like has protein and they formed trust
in me.
And so cooking conformed the Nitros the
means and you can ingest them.
So cured bacon with,
with chemicals is what's bad for you.
I don't,
I'm not a big fan of,
of eating nitrites daily or even weekly.
Um,
you know that I think if you love Bacon,
why not just buy the stuff without the
nitrites?
They make it without it.
You can get to the butcher shop where
it's not.
Right.
I think I've even seen it like at
Berkeley Bowl,
like we're,
we're a shop so it's not so are bad and
I traits
or plant formed and nitrates can form my
truck.
It's just,
I know it was like a little confusing
and complicated,
but commonly misconstrued commonly.
Yeah.
They commonly get.
Yes.
So yeah,
nine traits are not what are curing
meat.
Nitrates are Woodson plants and you can
form them.
You can form nitrites from them.
However,
because of all the vitamin C and all
that,
they don't readily form.
They chose the meetings I trust that
means which is the bad stuff,
that it's the carcinogen.
That's,
that's what you don't want to form.
It forms nitric oxide more readily so
and nitrites can form nitric oxide,
but they also form nitrogen means.
And particularly if there's not a lot of
vitamin C,
your antioxidants around,
they can get pushed towards that.
And I trust him.
Can State.
Yeah,
Uber complicated.
It's so complicated.
I've seen the switched.
I'm all over the place on the Internet
actually.
So I know a lot about it because my
mentor studied nitrospan means and he
was like one of the pioneering guys that
like was talking about how this DNA
damage causes cancer.
So I've,
he's told me about them,
you know,
so I know a little bit,
a little bit about them and he knows a
lot more than it.
So it just seems like one of those
things where when you're,
when you're talking about all these
different nutrients and you talking
about this is a real constant area of
study for anybody who wants to be
consistently healthy.
Anybody who really wants to have a
really nutritionally balanced diet and
optimize their health and their
potential to recover from illness and
prevent certain,
you know,
certain damage and free radicals and all
the areas that could be problematic in
our world and our diets.
This just so much to think about.
There's so much to calculate.
I,
yeah,
I think that,
um,
one of the main things I think that my
advice would be,
it's a lot easier to focus on what you
should eat then on what you shouldn't.
And I think that in more inclusionary
diet is,
is key.
So focusing on what your body needs,
you know,
not only for short term but what it
needs for longterm.
Focus on that more than focus on what
you're eliminated from your diet because
it's just,
first of all,
if you focus on what your limiting from
your diet,
then you're not going to be getting all
the good stuff that you need.
That's a lot about loss.
You're also thinking if you need that,
it's just like it's so there's too many
little.
It's easy to become caught up in a lot
of my new show and I know this because
I've been there.
And so,
you know,
getting caught up in all this little
minutia,
you know,
it can take you forever to try to figure
out what's going on.
And then in the meantime,
you're getting distracted from the
important thing is not as what you need.
You know your body,
your body is very resilient,
and if you feed it what it needs,
you can fight off stuff.
You're,
you're gonna,
you're gonna age better.
You know all these little chemical
reactions and enzymatic reactions going
on in all your cells,
in your liver and your kidney and your
brain.
All these things,
they're going to keep happening because
you're feeding it.
And when you have a little bit of toxic
stuff,
guess what?
All of these pathways are ready because
they're so they're getting nourished,
are getting what they need that they
activate in the.
Your body has protective mechanisms to
make sure it doesn't get cancer.
And you know,
I explained that when you make reactive
oxygen species,
you can repair it or you can see the
cell will die.
But all those,
all those repairs,
a stress response mechanisms,
they require that you know,
you're,
you're giving yourselves what they need
to do that.
So if you're so focused on what not to
eat that you're not getting enough of
what you need,
then your body is,
you know,
capacity to do that isn't gonna be as
optimal.
So I really like,
I really think it's easier,
especially for people that don't have a
scientific background that don't have
time.
I mean because it takes a lot of time to
sit there and read through all the
scientific studies and figure out what's
going on,
all the complex interactions,
you know,
I barely have time to do that and it's
like I do this every day.
Like I do research every day and on top
of that in my spare time I do.
And it's still overwhelming and I still
can only get so much done.
And you have the education to deal with
all the information and you understand
what's going on and the mechanisms
behind it.
Yeah.
Well,
you know,
last time we were here we talked about
some of the dis information that even
medical professionals,
guys who've written books that without
an understanding of the different,
like we talked about vitamin e and the,
the understanding of the different
mechanisms involved in vitamin D,
absorption in the body and people who
have written books that are incorrect
about the,
what's negative about high levels and
what is good about high levels and what
is,
you know,
what,
how your body should be processing it
and what different types of vitamin
either is just so there's so many
variables.
There's so much going on.
Uh,
yeah,
I think that in addition to so many
variables and it being so complex where
we're also continually finding out new
things,
you know,
I'm talking about studies that were
published two months ago in the context
of traumatic brain injury in some of
these neural stem cells.
I mean,
it takes a continual searching of the
literature,
you know,
to,
to keep up to date with all the new
research.
And,
and that's incredibly difficult to do
when you're occupied full time.
As for example,
as a physician and you're treating
patients already overworked,
you know,
these are things,
it's,
it's extremely difficult for a lot of
physicians.
First of all,
they haven't been trained in a lot of
these biochemical pathways in nutrition
and mechanisms.
I think that the training itself
inherently it's flawed.
Um,
and that's something that needs to be
changed at the institutional level.
You know,
I think that doctors need to be,
there needs to be more of a focus on
understanding how nutrition interacts
with genes,
how diet interacts with genes,
how these complex biochemical pathways,
why they,
why they need all these different
micronutrients as cofactors,
make enzymes work and all this stuff
that's not,
that's,
that's lacking in the medical
profession.
I know that talking [inaudible] I have
several friends that are physicians have
told me and also because,
you know,
even people that aren't my friends that
are physicians have told me that they
don't get trained in this way.
Um,
so I think that's really,
you know,
that's one of the flaws in medicine,
but in addition to that,
you have doctors that work really hard.
You know,
and I,
I respect them,
I think that they do to some degree,
you know,
they,
they train hard,
they work hard and they try,
they're trying to somehow help people.
They're trying to diagnose diseases and
um,
to some degree that,
you know,
they do do that.
But um,
I think the problem is that they also
can't keep up with all the new
literature that can't keep up with the
new research.
And then there's the whole human
component that comes in when you got
your patient that knows more about
something than you do.
Sometimes ego gets in the way and your
immediate response is sort of a jerk
knee response where it's like,
no,
this can't be true because I'm the
leader.
I'm the person that knows this.
And especially when you're talking about
things like you were talking about the
study with the mice,
the showing that the,
the neurons or actually it's stimulating
the stem cell growth that this is all so
new and you're talking about something
that's like a couple months old.
If your,
your degree was in the nineties,
good fucking luck.
No,
it's true.
It's,
you know,
it's,
I do like for me,
I,
I'm putting out some of these videos and
I do this,
you know,
I'm sort of,
I'm trying to do it more frequently,
but some of my videos are a little more
complex than like the general,
you know,
educational video.
Like I try to really be comprehensive
and bring it home and sort of,
you know,
make sure I explained mechanism and
context and all those things and I've
been getting emails from positions that
are thanking me because they're saying
they never knew this and they don't have
time.
And it's really rewarding in addition to
like educating the public,
you know,
like I think that's also very important
and making sure the public people that,
you know,
understanding how to prevent disease,
understanding what you need to try to
optimally optimally perform is as good
as you can now and to age as best as you
can.
That's important.
But it's also important for physicians
to understand the things that they
didn't get.
They didn't get trained in and they
don't have time to read about.
It's almost impossible if you have a
full practice and you're constantly
training people on a daily basis and
exactly how much education is involved
in getting a degree in nutrition.
Well,
I mean when you,
even if you're a doctor,
if your general practitioner,
how much of your time is really spent
learning about nutrition and when you go
to a doctor for advice but nutrition,
you're almost better off just fucking
googling it.
Yeah.
I don't know how much time.
I think that relatively speaking to the
rest of their training,
I would say it's not much.
Um,
and you know,
also getting into new degree in
nutrition is also.
I mean,
like I,
I got a degree in biomedical science and
I'm,
you know,
I've,
I've done research on aging cancer and
now I'm doing some nutrition research,
but I think that even getting a degree
in nutrition has flaws because,
you know,
I think that some of these,
some of the dogma with nutrition itself
is been changing with new science and
then getting people to like change their
state of mind.
I mean,
that's always harder to do,
especially when they've been spewing
this out for years and uh,
and also that a lot of,
you know,
degrees in nutrition,
like they don't have a real hardcore
science in some cases like a science
background where it's like,
I always liked,
I like to change fields.
I'm changing my,
I've changed my field several times,
you know,
I've started out doing chemistry,
looking at the very,
very molecular level and then I went
into aging research and then cancer and
now I'm doing nutrition and now I'm
getting,
now I'm even getting into the brain.
So I think that it's Kinda cool to also
have different perspectives like where
it's like because you see things that
other people had been in that field
forever don't see,
you know,
like,
the neural stem cells and there's not a
lot of nutrition people talking about
neural stem cells and things nutrition
that are important for that.
So it's,
yeah,
it's definitely,
it's hard for the,
for the average person to figure out
what they should eat or what they should
supplement.
I know that you were saying
one of the companies that you're
involved with does like nutritional
scans on people.
You'll do like a blood work panel and
then recommend what the person is
deficient in.
Yeah,
so I'm not involved with them.
I had done some.
I've done a couple of guest blog post.
I'm a little over a year ago to sort of
a because I liked what they were doing.
Basically.
I like the service.
They companies with wellness.
Fx wellness effects is cool because
they.
They are they,
they're basically consumer based where
it's like you sort of,
you don't have to go get a doctor's
prescription to go get your blood work
and to look at things like c reactive
protein,
your vitamin D levels,
you know,
your rbc,
magnesium,
your lipid profile,
you know,
these sorts of things.
Omega three they do.
They measure ea at EPA and Dha and they
also measured the Omega three to Omega
six ratio,
which is also important.
I mean having too much of omega six
fatty acids also leads to that
inflammation,
that generation of Youtube series,
prostoglandins and the brain and the
body.
It's causing inflammation in,
so having a,
having a good omega six to Omega three
ratio is also really good.
Um,
so they do that as well and I think that
people that are going to get these tests
done and then they get their blood work
and then they,
you know,
they'll wellness fx has like a panel of
nutritionists and other physicians I'm
not really familiar with.
They help people interpret and to what
degree they know what they're doing.
I can't tell you,
but the point is,
is that you have that information.
You can,
you can also learn a lot from the
internet,
but also you can,
uh,
look at your baseline and make dietary
changes and start to see how things
change.
Like that's really important.
You know,
this quantifying this quantified self
movement,
it's called where you're basically
quantifying your own thing,
you know,
blood work and things like that,
and figuring out how to optimize
yourself.
That's a lot of work.
It seems like it'd be really problematic
to find a lot of Rhonda Patrick's out
there though.
I don't know how many of you there are.
I'm not blowing smoke up your ass
because you're my friend and I love you,
but if there was 100 Rhonda Patrick's
out there running clinics,
who will be awesome.
That means 100 cities could have a place
where you could go and you could get
someone who's really completely absorbed
in this sort of research like you are,
give you a real systematic breakdown of
your diet.
Here's your profile.
This is what you're missing is.
This is fucking difficult.
Chip.
Well thank you for that compliment.
But I,
um,
I think that,
you know,
getting the blood work done and looking
at these different micronutrients and
biomarkers and liberal panel lipid
panels is one aspect of it.
And I think the other aspect that I'm
becoming increasingly interested in is
getting the genetic data as well,
like 23 and me.
So I,
you know,
I'm,
I'm trying to figure out a way somehow I
can.
I'm getting more and more interested in
because I'm looking a lot at these
complex interaction between genes and
diet and I'm trying to figure out,
okay,
you have this polymorphism.
You being me,
I have it.
Apo e four,
what do I do to make sure that I can
give myself the best chance of not
getting Alzheimer's disease,
excuse me,
what can I do for my father who is 65
years old now?
And it's at a critical point.
I got to make sure that if I don't
somehow intervene now and make sure he's
doing things right,
that he's going to get Alzheimer's and I
probably want that even.
I want to make sure he doesn't get it
even more than idea probably because you
know,
when you have it,
it's,
I feel bad for all my family members,
you know,
but I won't really know.
It's,
it's,
it's dealing with your close loved ones
and then completely losing their mind
and not remembering who you are.
I can't think of a worse thing that can
happen,
you know,
except from death.
Watched bunch of documentaries on people
with Alzheimer's and it's brutal.
And like I said,
I've seen the traumatic brain version of
it in fighters slowly start to appear.
And uh,
not just in real time but in the highly
accelerated real time.
Like I've seen a guy go from being one
way,
two to three fights later,
I see them a year later and he's a
different guy and this is fairly common.
I see this.
You can literally see the struggle in
their eyes.
Wow.
See the struggle in the way they formed
sentences.
Some of the.
I talked about some things that are
possible to help you know,
people that are getting traumatic brain
injury,
repetitive traumatic brain injury and
obviously I really,
I really think that the Aicpa we for
genetic test is.
I would love to see that come into
practice where we're talking adopted by
athletic commissions.
I'd like to see that adopted.
Yes.
I'd like to see it adopted by NFL.
I'd like to see boxing,
mma.
I'd like to see all those types of
athletic commissions adopted where it's
like,
you know,
I don't want to say,
okay,
well they're going to say your April
before you can't do that because I hate
to like take that away from someone,
you know.
I don't know.
Maybe maybe,
maybe people will figure it out and
there's some committee formed and
they'll say,
you know what?
It's such a high risk that we aren't
just can't.
Have you been a hemophiliac sword fight?
It is.
It really is.
It's just that bad.
I mean you're talking about going from
just having that a Lele I'm already
freaked out because I've got a two to
three fold risk of Alzheimer's disease
and you're talking about going from that
to attend in some cases,
you know,
10,
15 fold increase risk and and not only
increased risk,
it's an earlier onset.
It,
it changes the onset like by seven
years.
So you're talking about getting it 17
years,
almost a decade earlier than other
people.
So that Aaliyah like having that isoform
and it's just an easy,
it's an easy test to do.
Twenty three and me does it and doctors
do it as well.
No.
There was a really a recent study
published in the Journal of Alzheimer's
disease that reported neuroscientists
using a cellular model of the
Alzheimer's,
found low doses of Delta nine
tetrahydrocannabinol,
which is thc from marijuana actually has
been shown to reduce the production of
amyloid Beta and prevented abnormal
accumulation,
which is some of the early signs of
memory loss,
which is hilarious because marijuana has
been known to give people short term
memory loss.
I mean,
that's the one thing that pot heads like
myself constantly complaining about the
fuck was I just talking about you,
what would,
only when they're on it,
but when you were smoking marijuana or
eating it when you were intoxicated by
it.
The big thing is short term memory loss.
So it's interesting that you bring this
up because in my whole traumatic brain
injury quest,
as I've been reading about,
you know,
recently,
um,
cannabinoids came up on my radio radar
because new studies have just recently
come out related to als to also
traumatic brain injury where they found,
for example,
that patients that were admitted to the
hospital after a traumatic brain injury,
I think it was like a mild to mild to
moderate.
So it was like Glasgow Coma score of
four or five.
It wasn't like a severe,
severe,
like totally like,
you know,
in a coma and all that.
But they found that those people that
were admitted after having a traumatic
brain injury,
they,
those that had the highest levels of thc
in their blood were the least likely to
die.
And it was like
there was a dose dependent thing where
they saw people that had higher levels
were much less likely to die in the
hospital.
So that sort of sparked my interest in
like,
what's going on.
I did a short little research and I
found out that also,
even in mice mice that were given a low
dose of thc that was not high enough to
have a psychotropic effect.
Um,
it actually,
so they gave mice this low dose,
just a single low dose of thc either 48
hours before the traumatic injury.
So they induced traumatic injury in the
mice when they typically press put
pressure on their little tiny mouse
skulls and,
or they gave it to them one to seven
days after the traumatic event had
occurred.
And what they found was that it
dramatically reduced the whole neuro
inflammatory pathway.
There was less edema,
there was less inflammation,
less amyloid plaques were aggregated.
So this is quite significant.
Um,
so I started reading just a little bit
more.
I haven't done a ton of reading on this
topic,
so I really am no expert by any means.
So apparently there's two different
receptors.
Cannabinoid receptors in the brain,
there's a CB one and CB two,
CB one is found on neurons predominantly
in cb two is found on the Microglia,
which are the immune cells of the brain,
which is really interesting because
they're also found in the immune cells
in the body.
So it's like somebody about the CB two
receptor is specific to immune cells,
whether we're talking about immune cells
in the brain or in the periphery.
But what's interesting is that
cannabinoid activation of the CB two
receptors in the Microglia,
it prevents them from getting activated
and prevents them from throwing out all
sorts of cytokines and causing all sorts
of neuroinflammatory cycles that happen.
I don't know exactly how I think that
it's.
I think it's also well known that
cannabinoids have some sort of anti
inflammatory effect in general.
Um,
so that is one likely mechanism.
And the other thing was the CB one
receptors.
So they recently found this led me into
this Alzheimer's.
There was studies.
So the fact that it can protect from
traumatic brain injury is,
and it's that it's an anti inflammatory
effect,
is also is showing that this is relevant
for Alzheimer's.
So when I did a search on that,
sure enough,
yes,
it's like lots of studies actually had
been done on the effects of cannabinoids
on Alzheimer's.
And so,
um,
there was a recent study that showed
that somehow the,
the receptor,
when you agonize the receptor cb one
receptor on neurons,
it's,
um,
protects,
it does something where it's important
for longterm potentiation and it's kind
of a confusing mechanism,
but longterm potentiation is when you
have.
So during learning the learning process,
when you're learning something new and
you form,
you've got a synopsis forming between
the neurons and there's an enhancement
in that,
a signal.
So it's like it's enhanced.
So it's solidifying that memory,
that learning,
whatever you're learning,
it's making it stronger.
And that's a very important mechanism
for like neuroplasticity.
So making sure that you're going to
remember something longterm,
you know,
because you've enhanced that signal,
it's going to be there.
And to do that enhanced that a longterm
potentiation you can activate,
you can cause,
you know,
more like activating types of signals,
but you also get rid of the inhibitory
ones and the CB one receptor seems to
somehow get rid of those inhibitory ones
when it's activated.
And amyloid Beta plaques,
when they build up in the brain,
they,
they act,
they antagonized CB One receptor.
They prevent the CB one receptor from
doing that role.
It does in longterm potential
potentiation,
which is part of the,
the effects on memory long term memory
to um.
Now in terms of short term memory,
I don't really know.
It's kind of interesting because I had
the same thoughts I've heard that,
you know,
will short term memory's affected.
It's very stereotypical when you talk to
anyone on the street,
they've heard that 100 percent,
but I don't know that I would have to
read a lot more on this topic,
but there may be some sort of acute
versus chronic effect where it's like
there's something happening acutely
while you're,
you know,
agonizing them while you're,
while you're taking the cannabinoids and
then versus the longterm effect.
And maybe there's some sort of trade
off,
maybe it's like short term,
some things affected,
but in the longterm,
your,
your ability to have that longterm
potentiation is good.
Um,
so it's,
it's interesting the cannabinoid.
It's unfortunate that there's not a lot
of research being done in that field.
I think that more and more people are
doing more research on it.
As all these studies are coming out,
you just can't ignore it.
It's absolutely happening more and more.
Especially now that there's money
involved in it because of what's going
on in Colorado and Washington state.
There's so much money that's being
poured into marijuana research now
because people are starting to look at
it in terms of,
well this is some seriously financially
viable stuff like this is not just like
some sort of a fringe thing that people
trying to sneak in under the guise of
medicine.
This is a crop and we have to look at it
as this is a commodity.
I mean,
they're making hundreds of millions of
dollars now in taxes.
These states are,
Colorado is going to be over $100,
million dollars here.
Washington state might surpass it and
once all is said and done,
I mean it's gonna be crazy.
And once the new elections start rolling
in and these,
these,
uh,
options were on the ballot for other
states,
there's a lot of states that are
economically challenged that are going
to probably jump aboard and in
California should be an barest that they
have.
And especially with fucking Moonbeam
Jerry Brown in Sacramento,
the whole thing is ridiculous.
It should have been illegal a long,
long,
long time ago.
But,
um,
I think that there's going to be a lot
more studies being done on positive
effects because they're just,
they've looked at so many different
things.
The reduction of interocular pressure
for people that have glaucoma,
people have wasting disease and aids and
all sorts of people have a appetite
issues because of chemotherapy.
I mean,
you can go on and on and on,
but now when you're fighting all termers
the anti-inflammation properties of it,
um,
especially the differences between
eating it and smoking it,
you give,
you get more benefits from eating it.
A lot of people that complain about
chronic pain or hugely,
uh,
they find it hugely beneficial.
I mean,
it's a really good plan.
Yeah.
That's,
um,
I think you're right,
as,
as more and more research comes out,
there's going to be a positive feedback
loop where it's like you test and in
addition with all these other
progressive states like Colorado and
Washington state,
which are now,
you know,
it's recreational,
recreationally legal,
and it's not only that it's generating
income,
which is like,
you just can't ignore that.
I mean,
that's money.
The money's too big at this point and
people have a hard time ignoring money.
Well,
it'd be really hard for them to take it
away now because what happens is the
states get addicted to that tax revenue
when you're talking about withdrawing
$100,000,000
in tax revenue when the statistics,
here's where it gets really crazy
decrease in violent crime,
decrease in Dui arrests and over and
over and over,
there's like,
no,
there's no negatives.
There's like a.
God jumped off a roof somewhere like,
okay,
that fucking guy might've jumped off a
roof anywhere.
That's terrible.
Terrible,
terrible.
High driving,
even if you get in an accident,
you go into miles and hour.
Everybody's just bumping into each
other.
It's really relaxed,
hydrating accidents.
I mean,
we're talking about traumatic brain
injury.
I mean getting hit by a drunk driver.
I mean you're talking about.
It's awful.
It's just amazing.
Really,
truly amazing how few drunk driving
accidents there are in comparison to how
frequent the places where you can get
alcohol or as you're driving down the
street,
if you drive down the street and the
you drive down,
you have drug dealers all over the
place.
Every restaurant you pass a drug dealer.
Every cvs store is a drug dealer.
I mean,
they're all selling trucks.
They're all selling alcohol.
I mean,
almost every bar.
of course every bar,
but almost every restaurant,
almost every drug store,
they're all selling alcohol.
I mean,
it's incredible.
The availability of alcohol and if you
take that into consideration,
it's incredible how few alcohol related
accidents we really do have.
What's interesting is that they're
selling this drug that alcohol.
It does.
It does a lot of damage.
Alcohol does damage to your gut.
I mean,
you're talking about poking holes in
your gut like sugar does,
it does that.
It also obviously your liver,
that's what most people are familiar
with,
but the brain is my concern,
you know,
particularly because I can't repair
damage as efficiently as my husband who
has,
doesn't have this apl we for,
um,
so when you drink and they've even shown
in studies,
people with April before illegal that
drink alcohol even increase their risk
of Alzheimer's even
more because what,
you know,
when you're,
when you're talking about inducing cell
death,
then if you can't replenish that,
you know,
cell death,
if you can't repair that damage and
April we for can't.
When you have that Apl we afford it,
impairs the ability to grow new,
like I said,
grow new neurons and repair damage.
And that's very important.
Um,
it also,
it's so bad because it's also causing
more aggregation of amyloid Beta and all
that.
So that's the neurons are prime to die.
And when you had alcohol on top of that,
it's causing a tipping them over to
death.
That stress plus stress like I was
talking about.
So,
um,
you know,
I don't,
I don't drink a lot,
it's fun and I,
and I've always done it,
you know,
in social situations,
but after finding out about my April
before every time I am an associate
social situation,
if I'm having a dinner with them,
a bunch of friends and they give me a
glass of wine and even though there's
some benefits with polyphenols and the
wine resveratrol and one.
Yeah,
Rivera trials one,
um,
and,
but the problem is,
is that I,
the,
it's like the pros and cons.
The cons outweigh the benefits in my
mind because alcohol does so much damage
that I can't repair.
So if you and I are drinking a glass of
wine,
you know,
let's,
let's just assume that you're,
you don't have this April before because
one in four people have it.
There's three people in this room.
It's likely that neither of us,
Mike,
I'm the one me,
you know,
so,
but you know,
what I'm saying is that,
you know,
I have to think about this interaction
between the genes and the Diet and me
drinking the alcohol.
Now I know that I can't repair that
damage as efficiently,
so it's like it changes,
it changes my,
my future behavior and incense and some
people would probably say,
Whoa,
you're not going to enjoy life.
And you know,
it's like I'm not saying I don't ever
drink and I do a lot of other really,
really good things to counteract that,
counteract that.
And I'm trying to figure out more good
things.
But I think that knowing that,
like for example,
exercise exercise also,
you know,
it was very,
very important for people with April
before and they've shown this in studies
that people that exercise more,
um,
that have an April before Lele are less
likely to get it to get Alzheimer's.
So this is where this complex
interaction between genes and
environment come into play.
But it's interesting that cannabinoids
which are not found in every cvs store,
any store,
like within a block radius,
I'm actually have the opposite effect on
the brain.
And they actually help repair the
damage.
They actually decreased the
inflammation.
Um,
you know,
it makes people like me who are very
hyper aware of this Alzheimer's disease.
And all the mechanisms that are
accelerating it and how to stave it off,
it makes me think,
well,
that's kind of interesting that
something that's seems to be beneficial
from our,
from our studies that we've had
published so far.
Um,
you know,
so when will we see that adopted in the
medical community?
You know,
are we going to see changes?
Are we going to start to see people
given cannabinoids?
And,
you know,
I don't know if they're trying to figure
out a way to uncouple the psychotropic
effects from the anti inflammatory
effects.
I'm almost certain that people are
trying to figure that out.
And I don't know if that's gonna work or
not.
You know,
there may be something about the
psychotropic effect of it that's also
important for,
you know,
there's,
there's no telling biology.
I mean,
it's,
it's the way it is for a reason,
you know.
Um,
but,
uh,
it's,
it's something that's on my mind.
It's on my mind now that I,
you know,
especially that,
that I know I have this April,
we for a Lille,
which completely changes a lot of,
you know,
things that I.
When I think about exercise,
I don't think about exercise in the
sense of,
Oh,
I need to lose weight.
I want to stay toned and look good.
I think about it.
If I don't get exercise,
I am dramatically increasing my risk of
Alzheimer's disease.
If I don't get that exercise,
my brain is going to atrophy and I'm
going to move more.
It's going to be more likely that I'm
going to lose my brain function and I'm
going to change my behavior in older
age.
And that is terrifying,
terrifying,
you know,
so,
the exercise,
it's becoming like,
you know,
I think people still really think of it,
of it in terms of,
you know,
losing weight and it's just,
it's doing so much more.
It's doing so much more.
And,
uh,
you know,
I'm really glad that people do it to
lose weight because at least they're
doing it,
you know,
but they even just like a couple of
weeks ago,
a study came out showing that exercise
literally causes your muscle cells to
detoxify something that we made called
[inaudible],
which is actually a byproduct of
Tryptophan metabolism trip to fan,
as I've talked about before in our
conversations.
Can,
you know,
it was a precursor to Serotonin,
right?
So tryptophan and has to get into the
brain and in order when it gets into the
brain and make serotonin.
Well,
trippy fan can also form something
called [inaudible].
And when it forms [inaudible],
uh,
this happens under conditions of stress
or when you're in you,
when you,
when there's some sort of pathological
invader.
So it's like,
it's an important part of the Immuno
Immuno immunological response.
So kindness is important to make t
regulatory cells.
So,
I mean,
you obviously want to be able to have
this response mechanism.
However,
when you make too much kinder running,
not only his trip to fan not being made
into Serotonin in the brain because it's
getting sucked into this other pathway,
in addition,
kind uranian can cross the blood brain
barrier and it conformed something
called quinolinic acid,
which is like a neurotoxin.
It literally causes too much glutamate
to be released and it causes et Cetera,
toxicity in cell death,
and it activates Microglia so it causes
inflammation.
If you already have amyloid Beta plaques
in your brain,
great more activation of Microglia.
You're going to keep making more.
It's like feeding into that already
terrible cycle.
So exercise causes muscle cells to like
convert that kind urinating into a
another byproduct that can't get into
the brain.
So you're talking about another way that
you know,
exercise is protecting the brain.
In fact,
in these study that was published in
cell,
they found that these mice that they did
this in mouse models when they injected
the mice with Kenya earning it got into
the brain and caused all this neuro
toxicity sort of effects,
but it also costs depression,
caused them to have depression,
which of course,
you know,
inflammation in the brain depletes the
ability of the brain to release
Serotonin and that's one aspect of how
inflammations causing depression.
So you're not,
you're not making serotonin cause
depressive symptoms in these mice,
and they do all sorts of little studies
where they look at exploratory behavior
and all sorts of things in little mice.
Obviously humans are way more complex,
but then so when they made the mice
exercise,
the depressive symptoms went away.
The neuro toxicity that did better on
learning and memory test.
So yet another reason why,
you know,
exercise is freaking awesome for the
brain,
for depression,
for me to make sure I'm not going to get
Alzheimer's.
So for everybody,
for everybody,
we're out of time.
Unfortunately,
we just rattled through three hours at
an accelerated rate.
Yeah.
He just blasted through.
Yeah,
you were in a trance,
you were in a information disseminating
trans.
Well,
I certainly hope people learn stuff.
I barely learned.
They're going to have to go over it
again with a notepad and they're going
to google the shit out of it.
And,
and I think we got a lot out of this to
holy shit.
Every time we talk,
next time we got to talk about
cryotherapy is something that I've
started getting into my God,
we got to talk about that.
But God damn this was awesome.
Totally awesome.
So much.
So much cool stuff to talk more about
behavioral epigenetics because that's
fascinating.
Do it again in month or so whenever.
Thank you so much.
It's always awesome.
Your website.
Yeah.
So uh,
found my fitness.com
is where you can find me and all my
stuff.
Found my fitness on twitter,
found my fitness on twitter and also
I've got a new android APP coming out
there this afternoon so you can find it
a lunch so you can find it.
They're awesome.
And also I've got my patrion where I'm
now about to make a mile another my
first milestone.
So I'm pretty stoked about it and um,
which means I'm going to have to step up
my game and get some more creative works
out there for people to listen to.
Beautiful.
Awesome.
You're fantastic.
Thank you so much.
So it was a pleasure,
Rhonda.
Patrick,
ladies and gentlemen.
All right,
tomorrow Joe Perry from aerosmith.
Hala.
See you soon.
Bye.
Who.